This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. The poet Robert Frost wrote about two roads diverging in a yellow wood, a moment when a traveler must choose a path, not knowing where either one leads. In the poem, the traveler is indecisive, first looking down one path and then another. The last lines of that poem have become some of the most famous lines in American poetry. Two roads diverged in a wood, and I, I took the one less traveled by, and that has made all the difference. Perhaps you've had moments when you confronted a similar fork in the road.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。诗人罗伯特·弗罗斯特（Robert Frost）曾写过两条在黄树林中分叉的道路，那是旅行者必须做出选择的时刻，却不知道哪条路通向何方。在诗中，旅行者犹豫不决，先是看向一条路，然后又看向另一条。那首诗的最后几行已成为美国诗歌中最著名的诗句之一：“林中两路分叉，而我，我选择了人迹更少的一条，从此一切都变得不同。”也许你也曾遇到过类似的十字路口。
Should you stay in the city you're living in or move? Should you stay with the person you're with or leave? Should you stick with a job you have or look for a new one? Many of us peer down the different paths before us, trying to figure out which one will make us happy. But like that traveler in the woods, we find there isn't enough evidence one way or the other. We go weeks, months, or years, paralyzed by indecision.
你应该留在现在的城市还是搬走？你应该留在现在的伴侣身边还是离开？你应该坚持现在的工作还是寻找新工作？我们许多人都在审视面前不同的道路，试图弄清楚哪一条会让我们幸福。但就像树林里的那个旅行者一样，我们发现并没有足够的证据支持任何一方。我们可能会因为优柔寡断而陷入瘫痪，持续数周、数月甚至数年。
And then something happens. Maybe it's something big. We get a serious medical diagnosis or someone we love dies. Or maybe it's something small. You get a traffic ticket or someone looks at you funny. And all of a sudden, your dilemma is over. You know which way to go. You know which path to choose.
然后事情发生了。也许是一件大事。我们得到了严重的医疗诊断，或者我们所爱的人去世了。又或者是一件小事。你收到了一张交通罚单，或者有人用奇怪的眼神看你。突然之间，你的困境结束了。你知道该走哪条路。你知道该选择哪条路径。
Today on the show and in a companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, we examine the unexpected experiences that give us clarity. We look at how and why they are so powerful, and we explore techniques to make the best use of these moments. Stepping into the future and leaving the past behind. This week on Hidden Brain. All of our lives are made up by a series of moments. Most of them pass by without our notice.
今天在节目中，以及在《隐藏的大脑 Plus》的配套剧集中，我们将探讨那些带给我们清晰认知的意外经历。我们将审视它们为何如此强大，并探索如何充分利用这些时刻。迈向未来，将过去抛在身后。本周的《隐藏的大脑》。我们的一生由一系列时刻组成。其中大多数时刻都在我们毫无察觉中流逝。
We are busy, or we are on autopilot, or we are paying attention to something else. But all of us also have moments that stand out. At these times, you can suddenly see your own life clearly. You know what to do going forward. At University College London, psychologist Anthony Klott studies these moments. He spent years examining how they inform what we do and how they can reveal whom we want to become. Anthony Klotz, welcome to Hidden Brain.
我们很忙，或者处于自动驾驶模式，或者在关注其他事情。但我们每个人也都有一些脱颖而出的时刻。在这些时刻，你可以突然清晰地看到自己的人生。你知道未来该做什么。在伦敦大学学院，心理学家安东尼·克洛茨（Anthony Klotz）研究这些时刻。他花了多年时间研究它们如何影响我们的行为，以及它们如何揭示我们想要成为什么样的人。安东尼·克洛茨，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thanks for having me. Anthony, I want to start with an experience that you had all the way back in high school. You worked part-time at a lumberyard with a friend. What was the work like? Yeah, so it was on the evenings and weekends of my senior year of high school. I worked in a lumberyard where customers would come in and ask for their two-by-fours to be cut to certain lengths or their plywood to be cut in certain shapes. And it was my job to help them get what they needed for work.
谢谢邀请。安东尼，我想从你高中时的一次经历开始谈起。你曾和一个朋友在木材厂做兼职。那份工作是什么样的？是的，那是我高三的晚上和周末。我在一家木材厂工作，顾客会进来要求把他们的木板切成特定的长度，或者把胶合板切成特定的形状。我的工作就是帮助他们获得工作所需的东西。
whatever home improvement task they were taking on. So I understand that you and a friend were doing this work together. Was it a good work environment? What was the boss like? It was a really fun work environment, and I did work there with my good friend, and that made the hours pass quickly along with the work. Our boss, as he probably needed to be managing young students in a lumberyard, was pretty strict and stern, but that didn't really bother us.
无论他们正在进行什么样的家居装修任务。所以我了解到你和一个朋友一起做这份工作。那是一个好的工作环境吗？老板怎么样？那是一个非常有趣的工作环境，我和我的好朋友在那里工作，这让工作时间过得很快。我们的老板，正如他管理木材厂的年轻学生所需要的那样，非常严格和严肃，但这并没有真正困扰我们。
It was a good work environment. I enjoyed it. So at one point over the summer, both you and your friend needed some time off, and that led to something very interesting. Tell me the story of what happened. Yeah, so both my friend and I got called into the office one day by the boss, and he informed us that we had both requested vacation at the same time. And he said, one of you has to work here.
那是一个很好的工作环境。我很喜欢。那么在夏天某个时候，你和你的朋友都需要请假，这导致了一些非常有趣的事情。告诉我发生了什么事。是的，有一天我和朋友都被老板叫进办公室，他通知我们，我们俩都在同一时间申请了休假。他说，你们俩中必须有一个人留下来工作。
You can't both take vacation at the same time. But we explained we both had these separate family. the events that we needed to attend. And so both of us sat there in an impasse saying we both need to take this time off. I'm wondering how you heard this request from your boss that either you or your friend had to work. How did that come across to you, Anthony? It was somewhat surprising. I mean, I sort of empathized with him. He's trying to cover the shifts that are available and we're two of the main workers. But at the same time, I could tell that we both had events we weren't going to move. And so in my head as it was happening, I was wondering sort of how this was going to play out
你们不能同时休假。但我们解释说，我们都有各自需要参加的家庭活动。于是我们俩陷入了僵局，都说我们需要请假。我很好奇你是如何听到老板要求你们中必须有一个人留下来工作的。安东尼，这对你来说意味着什么？这有点令人惊讶。我的意思是，我有点同情他。他试图填补可用的轮班，而我们是主要员工中的两个。但与此同时，我能看出我们都有无法推迟的活动。所以当这件事发生时，我在脑海里想，这会如何收场。
both with him and my friend. How did it turn up? Well, neither of us budged. And our boss sort of got frustrated. And eventually he accused or said, I think the two of you planned this together. Like you're going somewhere to goof off or something like that. And at that moment, it sort of flipped because it seemed like maybe he was accusing us of lying or there was some trust breakdown here. So there was this awkward silence. And then almost at the same time, my friend and I said, I quit. And we took off our hard hats and unclipped our measuring tape and handed it to our boss and said, that's it. We're done.
无论是对他还是对我的朋友。结果如何？好吧，我们俩都没有让步。我们的老板有点沮丧。最终他指责或说，我想你们俩是串通好的。就像你们要去什么地方偷懒之类的。那一刻，情况发生了转变，因为看起来他好像在指责我们撒谎，或者这里存在某种信任破裂。于是出现了一阵尴尬的沉默。然后几乎在同一时间，我和朋友说，我不干了。我们摘下安全帽，解下卷尺，递给老板说，就这样吧。我们不干了。
It's almost like one of those Hollywood moments, right, when the worker is really frustrated and basically flings their paths down at the boss and walks out the door. That's exactly right. I mean, the stakes weren't incredibly high because this was a high school. job, but nonetheless, it did have a little bit of a Hollywood quality to it. So many years later, Anthony, you were working for the food company General Mills. For listeners who are not familiar with the company, describe the range of things the company does and what your role was at the company? Yes, so it's a food manufacturing and marketing company.
这就像好莱坞电影里的那种时刻，对吧，当员工感到非常沮丧，基本上把东西扔给老板然后走出门口。完全正确。我的意思是，赌注并不是特别高，因为这是一份高中工作，但尽管如此，它确实有一点好莱坞的色彩。多年后，安东尼，你在食品公司通用磨坊（General Mills）工作。对于不熟悉这家公司的听众，请描述一下该公司业务的范围以及你在公司的角色？是的，这是一家食品制造和营销公司。
Most people know it best because of the cereals that they make, like Cheerios, but they also own a number of other food brands, Old El Paso and Betty Crocker. and so forth. And so I worked in food manufacturing, and so I worked in a variety of different food manufacturing plants that made different products. I understand that at one point your job was to make sure there were enough ingredients at each of the plants to make products like Lucky Charms and Cheerios. And I'm guessing that one of the essential ingredients for these plants to function was flour and probably a lot of it. Yeah, that's exactly right. My role for a while in my very first job out of school was to be inbound planner for a cereal plant. And the main ingredient in cereal is
大多数人最了解它是因为他们生产的谷物食品，比如脆谷乐（Cheerios），但他们还拥有许多其他食品品牌，如 Old El Paso 和 Betty Crocker 等等。所以我从事食品制造业，在不同的食品制造工厂工作，生产不同的产品。我了解到，你曾经的工作是确保每个工厂都有足够的原料来生产像幸运符（Lucky Charms）和脆谷乐这样的产品。我猜这些工厂运作的基本原料之一是面粉，而且可能需要很多。是的，完全正确。我毕业后的第一份工作中，有一段时间我的角色是谷物工厂的入库计划员。而谷物的主要成分是
flour. And so as an inbound planner, my number one job is to not run out of flour. So something happened in the course of this job that in some ways was very consequential for your life. Tell me what happened. Yeah, so I had gotten my degree in logistics. And so this was a logistics planning job. And I even grew up in a family business in the field of logistics. And so I thought myself a pretty good planner. But when it turned out I was actually in this role, I tried to run inventories at a very tight level. And it turns out if you run inventories tight and you run short on one, you have to get a replacement for it pretty quickly. But one ingredient that's hard to replace quickly is flour because it comes by a slow rail car.
面粉。所以作为一名入库计划员，我的首要工作就是不能让面粉断货。所以在这份工作中发生了一件事，在某种程度上对你的人生影响深远。告诉我发生了什么。是的，我获得了物流学位。所以这是一份物流计划工作。我甚至是在一个从事物流行业的家族企业中长大的。所以我认为自己是一个相当不错的计划员。但当我真正担任这个角色时，我试图将库存保持在非常紧凑的水平。事实证明，如果你库存紧凑，一旦短缺，就必须很快找到替代品。但有一种原料很难快速更换，那就是面粉，因为它是由缓慢的铁路货车运输的。
And so while I was running inventories tight, there was a rail car delay. and the plant had to shut down because I ran it out of flour. Wait, the whole plant had to shut down? Yes, so we're talking tens of thousands of dollars in cost because of my inventory management practices. I mean, the main feeling that I had was embarrassment and shame over, you know, there were a lot of people counting on this plant for livelihood and a lot of people counting on it for their breakfast.
所以当我在紧凑运行库存时，发生了一次铁路货车延误。工厂不得不停工，因为我把面粉用完了。等等，整个工厂不得不停工？是的，因为我的库存管理做法，造成了数万美元的损失。我的意思是，我当时的主要感觉是尴尬和羞愧，你知道，有很多人指望这家工厂维持生计，也有很多人指望它提供早餐。
And so it was a pretty big early career failure. And of course, I worried that it was going to have a permanent impact on my career success. But then once I moved past those emotions, what really took over was this period of questioning. Is logistics what I want to do with my career? Am I actually good at this? I ended up switching. And by switching over from logistics to operations in that early career stage, it really changed what my next few. jobs were going to be. And so instead of going to Minneapolis, where, by the way, my wife had been
所以这是一个相当大的职业生涯早期失败。当然，我担心这会对我的职业成功产生永久性的影响。但当我克服了这些情绪后，真正占据主导地位的是一段质疑期。物流是我职业生涯想要从事的吗？我真的擅长这个吗？我最终转行了。通过在职业生涯早期从物流转向运营，这确实改变了我接下来的几份工作。所以，我没有去明尼阿波利斯，顺便说一句，我妻子已经在那里
accepted into grad school and we sort of planned to move and live there for a long time, ended up taking a transfer to Lodi, California, to another manufacturing plant. And then after that, another manufacturing plan. So it really really diverted the professional course of my career, as well as the personal course of our lives as well. So, Anthony, your experience at the lumberyard and at General Mills can show how a single moment, whether that's a mistake or a conversation, can get us out of the usual way we run our lives, which is most commonly on autopilot. I want to talk about how sometimes these moments that give us clarity can grow out of very small thoughts and feelings. You like to tell the story about a famous leader in the world of English soccer.
被研究生院录取了，我们原本计划搬到那里长期居住，结果我被调到了加利福尼亚州的洛迪（Lodi）的另一家制造工厂。在那之后，又是另一家制造工厂。所以它确实改变了我职业生涯的专业方向，也改变了我们生活的个人方向。所以，安东尼，你在木材厂和通用磨坊的经历可以说明，一个单一的时刻，无论是错误还是谈话，如何能让我们摆脱通常的生活方式，也就是最常见的自动驾驶模式。我想谈谈这些带给我们清晰认知的时刻有时是如何源于非常微小的想法和感受的。你喜欢讲述一位英国足球界著名领袖的故事。
Set it up for me. Who was this leader? And what was his public profile? Yeah. So, Yurgen Klopp was the manager. of Liverpool Football Club and was arguably one of the greatest managers not only in the Premier League, but in all of football. And he was coming off of several successful seasons. And back in November of 2024, Liverpool was at the top of the Premier League standings. And Juergen made a decision
为我铺垫一下。这位领袖是谁？他的公众形象是什么？是的。尤尔根·克洛普（Juergen Klopp）是利物浦足球俱乐部的主教练，可以说是不仅在英超联赛，而且在整个足球界最伟大的教练之一。他刚刚经历了几个成功的赛季。在2024年11月，利物浦在英超积分榜上名列前茅。尤尔根做出了一个决定
publicly that really shocked the football world. He said that he was going to step down as head coach of Liverpool at the end of the season. So behind the scene, something had shifted for Juergen Klopp. He said that I am not sure I am here then anymore. That's how he reported it later on. What did he mean by that? So what nobody on the outside could see was that Juergen had attended a team meeting of all the leaders of the team a few weeks prior.
公开宣布，这震惊了足球界。他说他将在赛季末辞去利物浦主教练的职务。所以在幕后，尤尔根·克洛普的心态发生了转变。他说：“我不确定我到那时是否还在那里。”这是他后来报告的。他是什么意思？所以外人无法看到的是，尤尔根在几周前参加了一次球队所有领导层的会议。
And in that meeting, they were discussing plans for the upcoming summer, what players to acquire, what players to let go. And as they were having this conversation about the future of the team, he had this thought pop into his head. I'm not sure if I'm going to be here then anymore. And that thought that seemed to come out of nowhere in his head surprised him. Why would I have that thought? So instead of just tossing that thought aside,
在那次会议上，他们正在讨论即将到来的夏天的计划，引进哪些球员，放走哪些球员。当他们进行关于球队未来的对话时，他脑子里突然冒出了一个想法。我不确定我到那时是否还在那里。那个似乎凭空出现在他脑海里的想法让他感到惊讶。我为什么会有这种想法？所以他没有直接把那个想法抛之脑后，
because he's in the midst of a very high-pressure season, in a very high-power visible position, he sat with that thought for a while and said, why did I have that? And as a result of that reflection, he came to two conclusions. The first conclusion was that his energy was not being replenished as quickly as it was being drained. And so while he had plenty of energy in the moment, he could foresee a time in the future when that wasn't the case anymore. And the second thing that he realized was that he wanted to spend some time being, quote, a normal person for a while, instead of one of the most visible figures in the world of football.
因为他正处于一个高压赛季中，处于一个权力巨大且引人注目的位置，他与那个想法共处了一段时间，并问自己，我为什么会有这种想法？经过反思，他得出了两个结论。第一个结论是，他的能量消耗速度快于补充速度。因此，虽然他当时有充足的能量，但他可以预见到未来某个时候情况将不再如此。第二件事他意识到，他想花点时间做一个“正常人”，而不是足球界最引人注目的公众人物之一。
How did he act on these thoughts, Anthony? He acted on these thoughts in what I feel is a very thoughtful manner. So he kept them to himself and to his inner circle. And then from what I understand, he shared it with the club, and they strategized the best way for him to depart in a way that causes minimal disruption to the club. How can we best do that? And so the way that the announcement of his first,
安东尼，他是如何根据这些想法采取行动的？他以一种我认为非常深思熟虑的方式采取了行动。他把这些想法留给自己和核心圈子。据我所知，他与俱乐部进行了沟通，他们制定了最佳的离职策略，以最大限度地减少对俱乐部的干扰。我们如何才能最好地做到这一点？所以他第一次宣布
resignation happened was through a video that the club put out. So it was the organization and him working together to communicate, here's what's happening, here's why it's happening. And he did it in somewhat of a fireside chat manner that really came across as genuine and humane. I want to play a little clip of how he explained his decision to his fans. I love absolutely everything about this club. I love everything about the city. I love everything about the city, I love everything, about our supporters. I love the team, love the stuff, love everything. But I know that I cannot do the job again and again and again and again and again. And the least thing I owe you is the truth.
辞职的方式是通过俱乐部发布的一段视频。这是组织和他共同努力沟通的结果：发生了什么，为什么会发生。他以一种类似炉边谈话的方式进行了沟通，显得非常真诚和人性化。我想播放一小段他向球迷解释自己决定的片段。我绝对热爱这家俱乐部的每一件事。我热爱这座城市的一切。我热爱这座城市的一切，我热爱一切，关于我们的支持者。我热爱这支球队，热爱员工，热爱一切。但我知道我不能一次又一次地重复这份工作。我欠你们最起码的就是真相。
What was the reaction to his announcement, Anthony? The reaction was clearly surprised. And for those of us who cheer for other teams other than Liverpool, The reaction was relief, like, oh, this amazing leader is going to step down and give the rest of our teams, the rest of our clubs a chance. But I can say, although there was surprise, there wasn't a wave of animosity or betrayal among the fan base because of how he handled it, because he handled it so professionally and expressing so much gratitude as he did it. So in time, Anthony, you decided to study. these moments when we reach a realization or have an epiphany, what was it that drew you to these turning points? It was actually when I was in graduate school and I spent a week studying what we know
安东尼，大家对他的宣布有什么反应？反应显然是惊讶。对于我们这些支持利物浦以外球队的人来说，反应是如释重负，就像，哦，这位伟大的领袖要退位了，给我们的球队、我们的俱乐部一个机会。但我可以说，虽然有惊讶，但球迷群体中并没有出现敌意或背叛的浪潮，因为他处理得非常好，他在宣布时表达了极大的感激之情。所以，安东尼，你后来决定研究这些我们获得顿悟或产生灵感的时刻，是什么吸引你关注这些转折点？实际上是在我读研究生的时候，我花了一周时间研究我们所知道的
about why employees quit their jobs. And I was thinking back to the times that I had quit my job or that I had seen others quit their jobs or when employees had quit when I was managing and what an emotional experience it was. And I was intrigued by two things really. First was this, a set of literature that surprised me and said often quitting doesn't result from this slow, rational decision-making process. About half the time, it results from these one-off events that make a stop and rethink work. The other thing that struck me about this literature was most of it was focused on the decision to quit, not what people do after they decide to quit or stay. And because, you know, I had had some interesting resignation experience.
关于员工为什么辞职。我回想起我辞职的时候，或者看到别人辞职的时候，或者当我管理时员工辞职的时候，那是一种多么情绪化的经历。我真的被两件事所吸引。首先是这套让我感到惊讶的文献，它说辞职往往不是源于这种缓慢、理性的决策过程。大约一半的时间，它源于这些让我们停下来重新思考工作的突发事件。关于这些文献，另一件让我印象深刻的事情是，大多数研究都集中在辞职的决定上，而不是人们在决定辞职或留下来之后做了什么。因为，你知道，我有一些有趣的辞职经历。
What I really wanted to study was not just why people quit, but how they do once they actually decide to do so. You call these moments jolts, as in these experiences jolt us out of our regular lives? Yeah, they go by a couple of names in the literature. One of them is jolts. One of them is shocks or career shocks. But they mean the same thing. They're these moments that knock us out of autopilot and cause us to rethink what's going on. in our work lives.
我真正想研究的不仅仅是人们为什么辞职，而是他们一旦决定辞职后会怎么做。你把这些时刻称为“震荡”（jolts），就像这些经历把我们从常规生活中震出来一样？是的，它们在文献中有几个名字。其中一个是“震荡”。另一个是“冲击”或“职业冲击”。但它们的意思是一样的。它们是那些把我们从自动驾驶模式中震出来，并导致我们重新思考工作生活中正在发生什么的时刻。
When we come back, how JOLs can point us toward the lives we want to lead and the people we want to become. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We all experience unexpected moments in our lives, moments we didn't ask for and might not have chosen.
回来后，我们将探讨“震荡”如何指引我们走向想要的生活和想要成为的人。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们生活中都会经历意想不到的时刻，那些我们没有要求、可能也没有选择的时刻。
A set back at work, a difficult conversation with a friend, a sudden realization of our own mortality. Most of the time, we treat disruptions in our lives as disruptions, things to get past quickly. But sometimes these disruptions can force us to step back and reassess. Psychologist Anthony Claude studies how and why these moments have a big impact on our choices, our careers, and even our identities. He says that if we learn to pay more attention to them, they can help us create lives that feel more intentional and better aligned with what we truly want.
工作中的挫折、与朋友的艰难谈话、对自己死亡的突然认知。大多数时候，我们将生活中的干扰视为干扰，即需要迅速克服的事情。但有时这些干扰会迫使我们退后一步并重新评估。心理学家安东尼·克洛茨研究这些时刻如何以及为何对我们的选择、职业甚至身份产生巨大影响。他说，如果我们学会更多地关注它们，它们可以帮助我们创造出更具意图性、更符合我们真正想要的生活。
Anthony, you've talked about how unexpected moments can force us to rethink our priorities. One example you point to comes from the actor Chris Hemsworth. For listeners who are not plugged into Hollywood, describe the famous role he's played as Thor, God of Thunder? So in these movies, well, he plays a god, Thor, with nearly unlimited power. And so, you know, it's a very strength-forward role. role. But what I think why fans really like Thor and the actor behind the character is because he has a
安东尼，你谈到意想不到的时刻如何迫使我们重新思考优先事项。你指出的一个例子来自演员克里斯·海姆斯沃斯（Chris Hemsworth）。对于不了解好莱坞的听众，请描述一下他饰演的雷神托尔（Thor, God of Thunder）这个著名角色？在这些电影中，他扮演的是一位拥有近乎无限力量的神，托尔。所以，你知道，这是一个非常强调力量的角色。但我认为粉丝们之所以真正喜欢托尔和角色背后的演员，是因为他有一种
sense of humor and a sense of self-awareness. And so often, despite his power and his seriousness, a lot of the laughs in these Avenger movies come from times when Thor is on screen and something funny is happening whether he knows it or not. And so I think that's why he's in a lot of people's hearts. Hello? So at one point in his career, he received some surprising health information. Describe for me the context and what he learned, Anthony? Yeah, so Hemsworth hosts a show called Limitless. And in this show, he puts himself through all of these physical and psychological tests
幽默感和自我意识。因此，尽管他拥有力量和严肃性，但这些《复仇者联盟》电影中很多笑点都来自托尔在银幕上，无论他是否知道，有趣的事情正在发生。所以我认为这就是他进入许多人心中的原因。你好？所以在他职业生涯的某个时刻，他收到了一些令人惊讶的健康信息。安东尼，请为我描述一下背景以及他学到了什么？是的，海姆斯沃斯主持了一个名为《无限》（Limitless）的节目。在这个节目中，他让自己经历所有这些身体和心理测试
to learn about human health and longevity and well-being. And in one episode, he took a DNA test. And he found out that in his DNA were a few genes that are linked with an increased potential for him to, to have Alzheimer's disease. And that really caught his attention, obviously. And he described it as this is my greatest fear because he knew it ran in his family. But at the same time, he described it as a blessing
来了解人类健康、长寿和福祉。在其中一集中，他做了 DNA 测试。他发现自己的 DNA 中有几个基因与他患阿尔茨海默病的潜在风险增加有关。这显然引起了他的注意。他将其描述为“这是我最大的恐惧”，因为他知道这在他的家族中有遗传。但与此同时，他将其描述为一种祝福
because he said, I'm learning this information while I'm still young enough that I can make changes. How did the discovery affect the way he thought about his work and his life? One of the reflections that he had as a result of this discovery was that he was spending more time on work and less time with his family than he wanted to. It was out of balance. And so that was one of the main takeaways was like, if I have these genes that could cause changes to my mind earlier than I would like them to,
因为他说：“我是在我还年轻、可以做出改变的时候了解到这些信息的。”这个发现如何影响了他对工作和生活的看法？作为这个发现的结果，他反思的一点是，他花在工作上的时间比他想要的要多，而陪伴家人的时间却太少。这失去了平衡。所以主要的收获之一是：如果我有这些可能导致我的思维比我希望的更早发生改变的基因，
I need to spend more time with my family now and perhaps a little bit less time working and perhaps a little more time on work that I actually care about. So it's a jolt where it instantly took him to thinking of, about his relationship with work and not necessarily overhauling it, but saying what are some tweaks that I can make to that relationship in order to bring it more in line with what I want out of life. You say that this idea of the jolt is similar to what the psychologist Dan McCadams refers to as nuclear events, whereas he puts it,
我现在需要花更多时间陪伴家人，也许少花一点时间工作，也许在真正关心的工作上多花一点时间。所以这是一个“震荡”，它立刻让他开始思考自己与工作的关系，不一定是彻底重组，而是说我可以在这种关系中做出哪些调整，以便使其更符合我想要的生活。你说“震荡”这个概念类似于心理学家丹·麦克亚当斯（Dan McAdams）所说的“核心事件”（nuclear events），正如他所说，
the me experienced a rather sudden or decided transformation. Yeah, I really like how that term nuclear events and how he describes them. He talks about these like scenes that stand out in bold print in our lives. And these could be positive or negative. It could be like a lucky break or a failure or a fall from grace. But yeah, one defining characteristic is that it does transform us often from being really self-focused to being a little bit more other-focused as well. One of the things that you and others have noticed is that a jolt in one domain of our life
“自我经历了一种相当突然或决定性的转变。”是的，我真的很喜欢“核心事件”这个术语以及他描述它们的方式。他谈到这些就像是我们生活中以粗体印刷出来的场景。这些可以是积极的，也可以是消极的。它可以是好运、失败或从高位跌落。但确实，一个决定性的特征是它确实改变了我们，通常是从非常关注自我转变为也稍微多关注他人。你和其他人注意到的一件事是，我们生活的一个领域中的“震荡”
can affect what we do in other domains of our life. And Chris Hemsworth, in some ways, is an example of that. That's exactly right. As his story shows, personal events outside of work can make us stop and rethink about our lives inside of work. And the inverse is true as well. Events that happen to us at work can make us rethink what's going on outside of it. And I suppose all of us have had the experience of having a very difficult day at work and then coming back to our families and finding that we are not behaving the way with our families that we might want to behave, because we have had the experience, because we're so stressed out about what happened at work.
可以影响我们在其他领域所做的事情。克里斯·海姆斯沃斯在某种程度上就是这方面的例子。完全正确。正如他的故事所展示的那样，工作之外的个人事件可以让我们停下来重新思考工作中的生活。反之亦然。工作中发生的事件可以让我们重新思考工作之外发生的事情。我想我们所有人都经历过在工作中度过非常艰难的一天，然后回到家人身边，发现我们对待家人的方式并不是我们想要的，因为我们经历了那些事情，因为我们对工作中发生的事情感到压力太大。
Yes. Sadly, we've all been there, right? And the research backs this up, that on days where we experience negative events at work, especially mistreatment, we're more burnt out at the end of the day, and that burnout comes home with us. And we end up being not as good of partners.
是的。可悲的是，我们都经历过，对吧？研究支持这一点，即在我们经历工作中的负面事件，尤其是受到虐待的日子里，我们在一天结束时会更加精疲力竭，而这种倦怠会带回家。我们最终无法成为好的伴侣。
We express more anger. We tend to be a little bit more withdrawn, and we tend to engage in more fights with family and friends outside of work. You also tell the story of Pat Tillman. I'm wondering if you can go back to the year 2000 and tell me who Pat Tillman was and what was happening in his life? Yeah, so in 2000, Pat Tillman was the starting safety for the Arizona Cardinals NFL football team. And he was arguably the best, if not one of the best safeties in the league, which is a position that, you know, a lot of people work really hard to get to, right, a professional athlete level. So in the following year, just after the start of the new NFL season, terrorists attacked the United States. This was the September 11th attacks.
我们表达更多的愤怒。我们往往会变得更加退缩，并且往往会与工作之外的家人和朋友发生更多的争吵。你还讲述了帕特·蒂尔曼（Pat Tillman）的故事。我想知道你是否可以回到2000年，告诉我帕特·蒂尔曼是谁，他的生活中发生了什么？是的，2000年，帕特·蒂尔曼是亚利桑那红雀队（Arizona Cardinals）NFL橄榄球队的首发安全卫。他可以说是联盟中最好的，如果不是最好的安全卫之一，这是一个很多人努力工作才能达到的位置，对吧，职业运动员水平。所以在接下来的一年，就在新 NFL 赛季开始后，恐怖分子袭击了美国。这就是9-11袭击事件。
What effect did it have on Pat Tillman, Anthony? Yeah, so when 9-11 happened, he talked about how, even though he didn't know anyone directly impacted by what happened in New York and elsewhere that day, it made him rethink what he was doing. and it made him realize how insignificant playing football was. And he said he thought about how good we have it in this country and that he hasn't really done anything to earn that. And so it really caused him to rethink what he was doing in his work life. I've always had a great deal of feeling for the flag. But even someone who considers themselves that way,
安东尼，这对帕特·蒂尔曼有什么影响？是的，当9-11发生时，他谈到尽管他不认识那天在纽约和其他地方受到直接影响的任何人，但这让他重新思考自己在做什么。这让他意识到踢橄榄球是多么微不足道。他说他想到我们在美国的生活是多么美好，而他并没有真正做任何事情来赢得这一切。所以这确实导致他重新思考他在工作生活中所做的事情。我一直对国旗有很深的感情。但即使是这样认为自己的人，
you just don't think about it all the time. You don't realize what it gives. You don't realize how great a life we have over here. even as athletes we'd moan every now and again about this or that. And if we ever just, you know, times like this, you stop and think about just how, not only how good we have it, but what kind of a system we live under, what freedoms were allowed. And that wasn't built overnight, and it's kind of the flag is a symbol of all that,
你也不会一直去想它。你没有意识到它给予了什么。你没有意识到我们在这里的生活是多么美好。即使作为运动员，我们也会时不时地抱怨这个或那个。如果我们只是，你知道，像这样的时刻，你停下来思考，不仅是我们拥有多么好的生活，还有我们生活在什么样的制度下，我们被允许拥有什么样的自由。那不是一夜之间建立起来的，国旗是这一切的象征，
a symbol of, you know, my great-grandfather was at Pearl Harbor, and a lot of my family has given up, you know, has gone and fought in wars. And I really haven't done a damn thing as far as, laying myself in the line like that. And so I have a great deal of respect for those that have and what the flag stands for. Tell me the rest of that story, Anthony. How did Pat Tillman take this jolt and change his life? So he finished out his contractual obligation to play that year. But after that year, he left the NFL and he joined the Army. Now, this was a significant decision. It received a lot of attention
一个象征，你知道，我的曾祖父在珍珠港，我的很多家人都放弃了，你知道，去参加了战争。而我真的什么都没做，没有像那样把自己置于危险之中。所以我对那些曾经这样做的人以及国旗所代表的东西怀有极大的敬意。安东尼，告诉我那个故事的其余部分。帕特·蒂尔曼是如何利用这个“震荡”并改变他人生的？所以他完成了那一年踢球的合同义务。但在那之后，他离开了 NFL，加入了陆军。现在，这是一个重大的决定。它受到了很多关注
at the time, not least because of the fact that he was walking away from something like $4 million a year, which was his salary playing for the Arizona Cardinals. Yeah, it's absolutely striking to see somebody who's not only earning $4 million a year, but also who has spent their whole life working toward that goal of reaching that level, a level that, again, many people aspire to get to. And so to walk away from that in service to a different or higher calling, Yeah, what was striking and obviously inspirational for a lot of people. So Pat Hillman signs up for the Army.
在当时，不仅因为他放弃了每年约400万美元的薪水，这是他为亚利桑那红雀队效力的薪水。是的，看到一个人不仅每年赚400万美元，而且一生都在为达到那个目标而努力，这是一个许多人渴望达到的水平，这绝对是令人震惊的。所以为了服务于一个不同或更高的使命而放弃这一切，是的，这令人震惊，显然对很多人来说是鼓舞人心的。所以帕特·蒂尔曼报名参军了。
Tell me what happens next, Anthony. Yes, he signed up for the Army and became an Army Ranger and did what he intended to do serve his country. But at the same time, tragically, he ended up dying in combat in Afghanistan. I'm wondering what you make of a story like this. At some level, it's a tragic story, but it's also, in many ways, an inspirational story. Yes, both of those things come to mind when I think of the Pat Tillman's story. But the main thing I think about is inspirational, someone who gave up on what a lot of us would aspire to in terms of worldly possessions, millions of dollars, in order to make the world a better place as he saw it.
安东尼，告诉我接下来发生了什么。是的，他报名参军并成为了一名陆军游骑兵，做了他打算做的事情——为国效力。但与此同时，悲剧性的是，他最终在阿富汗的战斗中牺牲了。我想知道你对这样的故事有什么看法。在某种程度上，这是一个悲剧性的故事，但在很多方面，它也是一个鼓舞人心的故事。是的，当我想到帕特·蒂尔曼的故事时，这两点都会浮现在脑海中。但我想到最多的还是鼓舞人心，有人放弃了我们许多人所渴望的世俗财产，数百万美元，为了在他看来让世界变得更美好。
He was asking those big questions and then having the courage to actually follow through on the answer, even though it meant him giving us. a career of fame and lots of money. When we come back, what to do the next time a jolt appears in your life? Also, in our companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, we're going to talk about how to recognize the signs that it might be time to leave a job and why so many people who do quit regret not quitting sooner. We'll explore when it makes sense to quit and also how to do it properly. If you're a subscriber, that episode,
他提出了那些宏大的问题，然后有勇气真正去执行答案，即使这意味着他放弃了名声和大量的金钱。回来后，下次“震荡”出现在你生活中时该怎么办？此外，在《隐藏的大脑 Plus》的配套剧集中，我们将讨论如何识别可能是时候辞职的迹象，以及为什么许多辞职的人后悔没有早点辞职。我们将探讨何时辞职是有意义的，以及如何正确地辞职。如果你是订阅者，那一集，
is available to you right now in this podcast feed. It's titled, I Quit. If you're not yet a subscriber, please sign up at support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, please go to apple.com slash hiddenbrain. You'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content. And again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org or apple.com slash hidden brain. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
现在就在这个播客订阅源中提供。标题是《我不干了》（I Quit）。如果你还不是订阅者，请在 support.hiddenbrain.org 注册。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com/hiddenbrain。你将立即获得我们所有订阅者专享内容的访问权限。再说一遍，是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.com/hiddenbrain。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
Have you had unexpected moments when you saw your life with a greater clarity than you ever had before? Did one of these moments prompt you to make dramatic changes in your life? If you have a personal story you would be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience or a question or comment about this episode,
你是否经历过意想不到的时刻，让你比以往任何时候都更清晰地看清自己的人生？这些时刻中的某一个是否促使你对生活做出了巨大的改变？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，或者关于这一集的问题或评论，
please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org using the subject line jolted. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org. When unexpected moments shake up our lives, they often stir up strong emotions. We might feel angry, afraid, or excited. These reactions can be powerful. They can push us to take action we've been avoiding. But psychologist Anthony Clarts says that if we respond to these moments purely on emotion, we can sometimes make choices that backfire. Anthony is the author of the book, Jolted, Why We Quit, When to Stay,
请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录制语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是 feedback@hiddenbrain.org，主题行使用“jolted”。再说一遍，是 feedback@hiddenbrain.org。当意想不到的时刻震动我们的生活时，它们往往会激起强烈的情绪。我们可能会感到愤怒、恐惧或兴奋。这些反应可能很强大。它们可以推动我们采取我们一直在回避的行动。但心理学家安东尼·克洛茨说，如果我们纯粹基于情绪来应对这些时刻，有时会做出适得其反的选择。安东尼是《震荡：为什么我们辞职，何时留下，以及为什么这很重要》（Jolted: Why We Quit, When to Stay, and Why It Matters）一书的作者。
and Why It Matters. Anthony, you've talked about how jolts can stir up strong emotions. Sometimes those emotions are so intense that people act on them instantly. When your boss at the lumberyard expressed distrust in you, both you and your friend quit on the spot. So researchers call this impulsive quitting. Do most people feel good about their decision to quit when they do it impulsively, Anthony? So we don't have a lot of research on exactly how people feel. But most of the time, unless you're in a situation where something really egregious happens, people end up experiencing some regret after impulsive quitting.
安东尼，你谈到“震荡”如何激起强烈的情绪。有时这些情绪非常强烈，以至于人们会立即采取行动。当你在木材厂的老板对你表示不信任时，你和你的朋友当场辞职了。所以研究人员称之为“冲动性辞职”。安东尼，大多数人在冲动辞职时对自己的决定感觉良好吗？我们没有关于人们确切感受的大量研究。但大多数时候，除非你处于发生了一些非常恶劣的事情的情况下，否则人们在冲动辞职后最终会感到后悔。
So that's not to say that there's never a time for it, but it is to say a lot of the time it does result. in regret. Now, there's something profoundly satisfying, of course, about saying, I quit and walking out the door. Yeah, most of the time in our relationship with organizations, they have the power. I mean, we need a paycheck, and they're the ones providing it. And so this is what makes quitting and especially impulsively quitting so attractive. It's this really empowering moment where the company doesn't have the power anymore.
所以这并不是说永远没有冲动辞职的时候，但它是说很多时候它确实会导致后悔。当然，说“我不干了”并走出门口，有一种深刻的满足感。是的，大多数时候，在我们与组织的关系中，他们拥有权力。我的意思是，我们需要薪水，而他们是提供薪水的人。所以这就是让辞职，尤其是冲动辞职如此吸引人的原因。这是一个非常赋权的时刻，公司不再拥有权力了。
They kind of need you as a worker and you're walking away from them. So I think almost all of us have had fantasies before multiple times over when something bad happens to us at work, impulsively quitting. And does the research say anything about why it is that people come to regret impulsive quitting to the extent that it's studied people who've made these impulsive decisions? Yeah, the regret really doesn't necessarily stem from walking away from the prior job. Usually when you impulsively quit, you have a pretty good reason that you're doing it. often the regret comes from, I probably should have taken my time and figured out what I'm going to do next. Because if you're not careful, you impulsively quit and then you put yourself in a position where I need another job. And so you go out on the job market, need a job quickly, take that next job, and find yourself in the same situation that you were already in just with a different company.
他们作为雇主需要你，而你正在离开他们。所以我认为我们几乎所有人在工作中发生坏事时，都曾多次幻想过冲动辞职。研究是否说明了为什么人们会后悔冲动辞职，就那些做出这些冲动决定的人而言？是的，后悔并不一定源于离开之前的工作。通常当你冲动辞职时，你有一个很好的理由。通常后悔来自于，我可能应该花点时间弄清楚接下来要做什么。因为如果你不小心，你冲动辞职了，然后你把自己置于一个“我需要另一份工作”的境地。所以你进入就业市场，急需一份工作，接受了下一份工作，结果发现自己处于与之前相同的境地，只是换了一家公司。
So that's mainly where that source of regret comes from, not necessarily from impulsively quitting, but from the situation. that impulsively quitting puts you in. You say that quitting is often glorified as a solution to our unhappiness. How so, Anthony? Well, I think it's glorified in the media. We see lots of wonderful movie scenes, whether it's in office space
所以这就是后悔的主要来源，不一定是因为冲动辞职，而是因为冲动辞职让你陷入的境地。你说辞职通常被美化为我们不快乐的解决方案。安东尼，怎么说？嗯，我认为它在媒体中被美化了。我们看到了许多精彩的电影场景，无论是在《办公空间》（Office Space）
or eat, pray, love, or Jerry Maguire that shows a dramatic quitting scene. Pop singers sing about it. There was a song, I think, last year or the year before by Beyonce, where she talks about being frustrated with her job in quitting. And so it is glorified. And especially in the wake of the pandemic when there was a wave of resignations, people increasingly went online and shared stories of their quitting and wrote about their quitting. And I do think it's, you know, a very empowering story
还是《美食、祈祷和恋爱》（Eat, Pray, Love），或者《甜心先生》（Jerry Maguire）中，都展示了戏剧性的辞职场景。流行歌手唱着关于它的歌。我想去年或前年有一首碧昂丝（Beyonce）的歌，她谈到了对工作感到沮丧并辞职。所以它被美化了。特别是在疫情之后，出现了一波辞职潮，人们越来越多地在网上分享他们的辞职故事并撰写关于辞职的文章。我确实认为这是一个非常赋权的故事，
that so much of our lives, we maybe work in situations that we don't want to work in. And so walking away from that is something that we like to hear those stories about. And it, you know, even if we can't quit, we can see other people doing it and say, I'm not alone in feeling like I want to walk off the job right now. You know, this is a normal human experience. And so, I mean, keep in mind quitting is a topic that you can't necessarily talk about at work. It's a somewhat sensitive topic. So when you see it, when you see it in movies, when you hear about it in a start, when you see it online, it really does connect you with this universal feeling, this universal impulse among workers, that when the going gets tough, quitting can be a great option.
我们生活中很大一部分时间，可能在不想要的工作环境中工作。所以离开那种环境是我们喜欢听到的故事。而且，你知道，即使我们不能辞职，我们也可以看到别人这样做并说，我不是唯一一个感觉现在想辞职的人。你知道，这是一种正常的人类体验。所以，我的意思是，请记住，辞职是一个你未必能在工作中谈论的话题。这是一个有点敏感的话题。所以当你看到它时，当你在电影中看到它时，当你听到关于它的故事时，当你在网上看到它时，它确实让你与这种普遍的感觉、这种员工中普遍的冲动联系起来：当情况变得艰难时，辞职可能是一个很好的选择。
And I suppose that when you see someone post something on social media saying that they walked off the job and you see that, you know, that post received, you know, a ton of likes, you can get the sense that maybe everyone except you is in fact quitting their jobs. Yeah, and I think that's the downside and the danger of how much content there is about quitting is that it is actually a fairly rare event in the course of our careers. There are lots of surveys that come out that show that some large percentage or the majority of individuals intend to quit their job over the next year. But in reality, only a fairly small fraction of those individuals actually turn
我想当你在社交媒体上看到有人发帖说他们辞职了，并且你看到那个帖子获得了大量的点赞，你可能会觉得也许除了你之外，每个人都在辞职。是的，我认为这就是关于辞职的内容如此之多的负面影响和危险，即它实际上是我们职业生涯中相当罕见的事件。有很多调查显示，很大比例或大多数个人打算在明年辞职。但实际上，只有相当小的一部分人真正采取了行动。
turn those intentions into reality. But if you look online, you can get the feeling everybody's quitting except me. Now, of course, it's worth pointing out that being able to quit and walk off a job is in of itself a privilege. Not everyone is able to do it. But you also point out that if it's a mistake to react impulsively to a jolt, you know, the other mistake you can make is to ignore it altogether. That doesn't make sense either.
将这些意图变为现实。但如果你上网看看，你会觉得除了我以外，每个人都在辞职。当然，值得指出的是，能够辞职并离开一份工作本身就是一种特权。并不是每个人都能做到这一点。但你也指出，如果对突发事件做出冲动反应是错误的，那么另一种错误就是完全忽视它。那也说不通。
Yeah, there's this middle ground that I encourage people to move into. we're going to experience these different types of jolts many times over the course of our career. And most of the time quitting will not be an option for most of us. And so it's tempting just to take that jolt and set it aside or put it out of mind, completely ignore it. But in doing so, we're missing an opportunity to potentially improve our relationship with work and fix a problem with it. So you have a number of suggestions on how people should think about their intentions to quit. and whether it's the right thing to do, when someone experiences a jolt,
是的，我鼓励人们进入这种中间地带。在我们的职业生涯中，我们将多次经历这些不同类型的突发事件。而且大多数时候，辞职对我们大多数人来说都不是一个选择。因此，人们很容易仅仅接受这种冲击，然后把它放在一边或抛诸脑后，完全忽略它。但这样做，我们就错过了一个可能改善我们与工作关系并解决其中问题的机会。所以，你对人们应该如何思考他们的辞职意图，以及当某人经历突发事件时，这是否是正确的做法，有一些建议，
you advise them, for example, to both zoom in and zoom out. What do you mean by those terms? I encourage people, you know, to really think through their job from a few different angles. So in terms of zooming in and zooming out, we can think of our job in two different ways
你建议他们，例如，既要放大又要缩小。你所说的这些术语是什么意思？我鼓励人们，你知道，真正从几个不同的角度来思考他们的工作。因此，就放大和缩小而言，我们可以用两种不同的方式来思考我们的工作
or as researchers say, at two different levels of construal. So we can think about it from the very low level of construal, a very concrete way of thinking about our jobs. What do we do in our, day-to-day work lives. And so I encourage people to zoom in and say, do I enjoy this job on a day-to-day basis? And when you're thinking about that, there's really two big buckets that you can
或者正如研究人员所说，在两个不同的解释水平上。因此，我们可以从非常低的解释水平来思考它，这是一种非常具体的思考工作的方式。我们在日常工作生活中做什么。所以我鼓励人们放大并问自己，我是否在日常基础上享受这份工作？当你思考这个问题时，确实有两个大类你可以
think about. Do I enjoy my work tasks and do I enjoy the people with whom I'm working on a day-to-day basis? And then we can zoom out to this high level of construal and think more abstractly about our jobs over the long term. So over the arc of my career, my life, in terms of what I want to accomplish, is this job moving me more towards those goals or is it pulling me further away from them? So at a high level, where is this job taking me in terms of the purpose and meaning or the goals I have for my life? You say that there are different ways to respond to a setback at work. And one is to follow the lead of Bob Eiger at Disney. Tell me that story, Anthony. Yeah, so fairly early in his career, Bob Eiger was an executive at ABC Sports. And this was back in the heyday of network sports
考虑。我是否享受我的工作任务，我是否享受我每天与之共事的人？然后我们可以缩小到这种高水平的解释，并从长远角度更抽象地思考我们的工作。因此，在我的职业生涯、我的人生轨迹中，就我想实现的目标而言，这份工作是让我更接近这些目标，还是让我离它们更远？所以从高层次来看，就我的人生目标和意义而言，这份工作把我带向了哪里？你说在工作中应对挫折有不同的方式。其中之一是效仿迪士尼的鲍勃·艾格。告诉我那个故事，安东尼。是的，在他职业生涯的早期，鲍勃·艾格是美国广播公司体育部的一名高管。那是在网络体育的鼎盛时期
programs. And so you can imagine, you know, he talks about flights on the Concord and Champaign and designer suits and unlimited expense budgets, these sorts of things. And he really enjoyed it. But then ABC, as a company, was bought up by this Warren Buffett-backed radio conglomerate. And this This radio conglomerate Cap Cities was known for running a very frugal operation. And so you can imagine this was quite the jolt, realizing that your work lifestyle and the way you were working was going to come to an abrupt change because your flashy network company has been bought up by a company with a bunch of radio stations. So Bob was tempted to leave. And he was tempted to leave also by what's called a collateral jolt. A number of his close coworkers were leaving. They were leaving to go jolt. this flashy sports agency, so they could essentially continue the work that they were doing,
节目。所以你可以想象，你知道，他谈论乘坐协和式飞机、喝香槟、穿名牌西装和无限的差旅预算，这些事情。他真的很享受。但后来，美国广播公司作为一家公司，被这家由沃伦·巴菲特支持的广播集团收购了。而这家广播集团 Cap Cities 以经营非常节俭的业务而闻名。所以你可以想象这真是一个巨大的冲击，意识到你的工作生活方式和你工作的方式将发生突然的改变，因为你那华丽的网络公司被一家拥有一堆广播电台的公司收购了。所以鲍勃很想离开。而且他也被所谓的附带冲击所诱惑。他的一些亲密同事正在离开。他们离开去加入
you know, getting paid a lot, working with athletes and so forth, rather than stick around. And Bob decided, yeah, I want to do the same thing. I'm going to join him. So he went to HR and informed HR, I'm going to leave. And HR said, why don't you take some time to think about that? First, there's some contractual things to work through. But more importantly than that, you might have a pretty bright future with this company, even though it's quite different from the place that you came from. And so Bob slowed down. He went home and talked it over with his partner
那个华丽的体育经纪公司，这样他们基本上可以继续他们正在做的工作，
and came to the conclusion, I've made a pretty good career here at this company, and just because it's changing hands doesn't mean I need to stop that. And so he stayed with what became Cap Cities, which was later bought by Disney, and over the course of his career, became CEO and chairman at Disney and actually ended up, you know, doing two spells at that role of CEO and chairman. So regardless of how you think about his leadership style, I think the story in terms of
你知道，赚很多钱，与运动员合作等等，而不是留下来。鲍勃决定，是的，我想做同样的事情。我要加入他们。所以他去了人力资源部并通知人力资源部，我要辞职。人力资源部说，你为什么不花点时间考虑一下呢？首先，有一些合同方面的事情需要处理。但更重要的是，你在这家公司可能有一个非常光明的未来，即使它和你来的地方完全不同。所以鲍勃放慢了脚步。他回家和他的伴侣商量了这件事
careers is sometimes the smartest response to jolts that leads to the most career success is actually doing nothing, is actually staying put in the wake of a jolt when you're tempted to bolt. And of course, that makes sense when you consider the fact that in the course of a career, we're all going to experience setbacks and challenges. And if we respond to each of them by deciding we're going to quit, we're not going to stay in any job for very long. That's exactly right. It'll be a career filled with changing jobs, which isn't necessarily bad. But again, I mentioned earlier, changing jobs often comes with some regret and it comes with a lot of uncertainty. And so having a career full of that can be a pretty risky career
并得出结论，我在这家公司建立了一个相当不错的职业生涯，仅仅因为它易手并不意味着我需要停止这一切。所以他留在了后来成为 Cap Cities 的公司，该公司后来被迪士尼收购，在他的职业生涯中，他成为了迪士尼的首席执行官和董事长，实际上最终，你知道，在首席执行官和董事长的职位上做了两任。所以无论你怎么看待他的领导风格，我认为在职业生涯方面，这个故事
strategy. Now, carrying on and sticking with what you're doing can sometimes be really difficult. You tell the story of your friend Jenny and what happened to her in her workplace. Tell me that story, Anthony. So Jenny works in a hospital, and she worked in an area of the hospital where there were several desks in the same room where they were all completing the same tasks. And she worked with a toxic coworker. And she found her well-being and her work satisfaction continually decreasing. as she worked with this coworker. But she felt like she could put up with it, even though her mental well-being was suffering as a result of this.
有时，应对突发事件并带来最大职业成功的明智反应实际上是无所作为，实际上是在你想要逃跑时在突发事件发生后保持原位。当然，当你考虑到在职业生涯中，我们都会经历挫折和挑战这一事实时，这是有道理的。如果我们通过决定辞职来应对每一个挫折，我们就不会在任何工作中待太久。完全正确。那将是一个充满换工作的职业生涯，这并不一定不好。但同样，我之前提到过，换工作通常会伴随着一些遗憾，并且伴随着很多不确定性。所以拥有一个充满这种经历的职业生涯可能是一个相当冒险的职业
But one day, she walked into that office, and before she even said anything, her coworker started not necessarily insulting her, but causing some problems. And Jenny thought, what am I doing here? Where the second I walk in the office, this toxic person is already creating negativity for me. And so she knew, as a result,
策略。现在，坚持下去并坚持你正在做的事情有时真的很难。你讲了你的朋友珍妮的故事，以及她在工作场所发生了什么。告诉我那个故事，安东尼。所以珍妮在一家医院工作，她在医院的一个区域工作，同一个房间里有几张桌子，他们都在完成同样的任务。她和一个有毒的同事一起工作。她发现她的幸福感和工作满意度在持续下降。当她和这个同事一起工作时。但她觉得她可以忍受，尽管她的心理健康因此受到了影响。
after that one moment, I had to do something about it. And so she looked around the hospital to see if there was an empty office anywhere. And she found one. And so then she went to her boss and said, look, here's an interpersonal situation that we're having. She didn't throw the other person under the bus. She said there's just this incompatibility here. I found this other office. Can I move to it?
但有一天，她走进那个办公室，在她还没说什么之前，她的同事就开始不一定是侮辱她，而是制造一些麻烦。珍妮心想，我在这里做什么？我走进办公室的那一刻，这个有毒的人就已经在为我制造负面情绪了。所以她知道，结果，
And her boss said, sure. And so she got her stuff and she moved to the other office. And then after a couple weeks of working in that office, she realized, like, I can actually divide our work tasks such that I don't even have to interact with my old coworker very much at all. And so it's kind of a win, really, for both of those coworkers that Jenny is now in an office on the other side of the hospital doing her work tasks. And her job satisfaction is through the roof. She loves it. And it was all a result of her boss just saying yes to a couple of creative suggestions she had about, you know, moving across the hospital and divvying up tasks.
在那一刻之后，我必须对此做点什么。所以她在医院里四处寻找，看看有没有空办公室。她找到了一个。于是她去找她的老板说，看，这是我们正在经历的人际关系情况。她没有把另一个人推到火坑里。她说这里只是存在这种不兼容。我找到了另一个办公室。我可以搬到那里去吗？
So this is an example of someone who didn't just stay the course and say, you know, I'm going to keep my head down and keep doing what I'm doing, but someone who said there's a problem, I'm not going to quit, but I'm going to speak up about it. That's exactly right. This, you know, Jenny realized that simply doing nothing wasn't sustainable. And so I have to do something. And so I have to be proactive about this and try to find the solution. to the jolt myself.
她的老板说，当然。于是她拿了她的东西，搬到了另一个办公室。然后在那个办公室工作了几周后，她意识到，我可以把我们的工作任务分开，这样我甚至根本不需要和我的旧同事互动。所以这对于那两个同事来说确实是一种双赢，珍妮现在在医院的另一边做她的工作任务。她的工作满意度非常高。她很喜欢。这一切都是因为她的老板对她关于搬到医院对面和分担任务的一些创造性建议说了是。
You offer suggestions to people on how they can speak up at work. You have ideas on what could make that more effective or less effective. What ideas would you have if someone decides they're not going to quit? They're going to stay in the job. They're going to speak up and maybe have a conversation with their boss. How should they go about doing that? Yeah, so this is not easy to do. Speaking up to power can be quite challenging.
所以这是一个例子，有人没有只是坚持下去并说，你知道，我要保持低调，继续做我正在做的事情，而是有人说有一个问题，我不会辞职，但我会大声说出来。完全正确。这，你知道，珍妮意识到仅仅无所作为是不可持续的。所以我必须做点什么。所以我必须对此采取主动，并尝试自己找到解决突发事件的方法。
And this isn't a situation where you say to your boss, I'm thinking about quitting or anything like that. Essentially, a jolt has revealed some problem in your relationship with your job, and you think that it might be fixable. And so you're going to bring up a problem with your boss. But there are some tips here. When it comes to speaking up to power, there's a few ways you can increase the odds of it being successful like it was in Jenny's case. So the first one is make sure you don't just have a problem. You have a solution to the problem. Many managers like this somewhat tired phrase of don't bring me problems, bring me solutions. In this case, that phrase holds up.
你为人们提供了关于他们如何在工作中大声说出的建议。你有关于什么能让它更有效或更不有效的想法。如果有人决定他们不会辞职，你有什么想法？他们会留在工作中。他们会大声说出来，也许会和他们的老板谈谈。他们应该怎么做？是的，这并不容易做到。对权力大声说出来可能相当具有挑战性。
You should have a solution. And here's the deal. In terms of the solution you have to the problem, it can't only benefit you. Like, you need to be a bit of a salesperson here and say, this solution not only benefits me, but it also benefits you or the customers or other coworkers or the company's bottom line somehow. So try to come up with a solution in a case. that doesn't only benefit you. And then, you know, the last one is, especially as Americans, but others as well, sometimes
而且这不是那种你对老板说，我正在考虑辞职或类似事情的情况。本质上，一个突发事件揭示了你与工作关系中的一些问题，你认为它可能是可以修复的。所以你要向你的老板提出一个问题。但这里有一些提示。当涉及到对权力大声说出来时，有几种方法可以增加它像珍妮那样成功的几率。所以第一个是确保你不仅仅有一个问题。你有一个解决问题的方案。许多经理喜欢这种有点陈词滥调的短语，不要带给我问题，带给我解决方案。在这种情况下，这句话是成立的。
like to deliver tough messages sandwiched in between to positive messages. The research shows that this is really ineffective when it comes to voice and challenging. So you may be tempted to say some nice things about your boss and then slip in the like, here's the real problem with my work. that's not effective at all. And then finally, I mean, if you're in the unfortunate situation of having a fairly domineering boss, research shows that this is especially tough to bring up problems. And so it's often better to phrase it in the form of a question than any sort of demand or
你应该有一个解决方案。这就是交易。就你对问题的解决方案而言，它不能只对你有好处。就像，你需要在这里做一个推销员，说，这个解决方案不仅对我有利，而且对你、客户、其他同事或公司的底线也有利。所以试着想出一个解决方案，在某种情况下。这不仅仅对你有好处。然后，你知道，最后一个是，特别是作为美国人，但其他人也是，有时
suggestion. Like, maybe this is a thought that we could have me work in this different side of the hospital. But hopefully most of us are in. a better situation than that. You've pointed out that one of the advantages of speaking up is that even if nothing changes and we eventually decide to leave, we can walk away knowing that at least we tried. How does using our voice protect us from the kind of what-if thinking that often leads to regret, Anthony?
喜欢在两个积极的信息之间夹杂艰难的信息。研究表明，当涉及到表达和挑战时，这是非常无效的。所以你可能很想对你的老板说一些好话，然后顺便提一下，这是我工作中的真正问题。那一点也不有效。最后，我的意思是，如果你处于有一个相当专横的老板的不幸境地，研究表明提出问题尤其困难。所以通常最好以问题的形式提出，而不是任何形式的要求或
I often heard this and continue to hear this a lot when it comes to exit interviews, where an employee says, I'm quitting because of these three reasons. and the company says, if you would have brought these up, we could have fixed these. The nice thing about speaking up is you get rid of these what-if scenarios and you find out what is. So if you're approaching quitting time, if you think I'm probably going to quit this job because of these two reasons, what's the harm in bringing up those two reasons and suggesting a solution to them? At least then you'll walk away knowing I tried to fix this and they weren't going to budge. on these issues, and that will reduce any regret that you might experience in the future.
建议。比如，也许这是一个我们可以让我在这家医院的不同侧面工作的想法。但希望我们大多数人处于。比那更好的情况。你指出，大声说出的好处之一是，即使什么都没有改变，我们最终决定离开，我们也可以知道至少我们尝试过。使用我们的声音如何保护我们免受经常导致遗憾的假设性思维的影响，安东尼？
A reminder, have you had unexpected moments when you saw your life with a greater clarity than you ever had before? Did one of those moments prompt you to make dramatic changes in your life? If you have a personal story you would be willing to share with a hidden brain audience or a question or comment about this episode, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the file to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line jolted. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org. I'm wondering whether you can think of any times in your life when you have been jolted and you have followed one of these paths, Anthony? Yeah. So in my own career in life, I've had jolts where I've followed all of these paths.
我经常听到这个，并且在离职面谈时继续听到很多，员工说，我辞职是因为这三个原因。而公司说，如果你早点提出来，我们本可以解决这些问题。大声说出的好处是你摆脱了这些假设场景，你发现了什么是真实的。所以如果你接近辞职时间，如果你认为我可能会因为这两个原因辞职，那么提出这两个原因并建议一个解决方案有什么坏处呢？至少那时你会知道我尝试过修复这个问题，而他们不会在这些问题上让步，这将减少你未来可能经历的任何遗憾。
So there was one academic conference in particular where I went to that conference and I found out over the course of one day through three different interactions that three different current coworkers of mine were on the job market looking for another job. All three of these people were my close friends. And so I experienced a pretty big what I call collateral jolt that day where I thought to myself, three of my good friends at work are looking. to leave. And if I stick around, what type of a department is that going to be and how much work am I going to have to take on? And why aren't I thinking about leaving too? And so I ended up going and doing an interview at that other institution and accepting a job there. And the irony of it is my three co-workers who were looking to move, ended up staying, but I ended up leaving. And so that's a moment I think back on is one of the more jolting days in my life for sure.
提醒一下，你是否有过意想不到的时刻，当你比以往任何时候都更清晰地看到你的生活？其中一个时刻是否促使你对生活做出巨大的改变？如果你有一个愿意与 Hidden Brain 听众分享的个人故事，或者关于这一集的问题或评论，请找一个非常安静的房间，在你的手机上录制语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，地址是 feedback at hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行 jolted。再说一遍，那是 feedback at hiddenbrain.org。我想知道你是否能想到你生命中被震撼并遵循了这些路径之一的任何时候，安东尼？是的。所以在我自己的职业生涯和生活中，我经历过突发事件，我遵循了所有这些路径。
And looking back, do you feel like you made the right call, Anthony? Yes, absolutely. And, you know, making that move to the different institution allowed me to do things in my career that I wanted to do, that I wouldn't have ever been able to do. But that's not to say, you know, if I would have stayed put and instead spoken up and asked for a raise, let's say. Like, look, everybody else is looking for a job except me. I should get a raise. Who knows? Maybe they would have, you know, given me a raise and some other perks.
所以特别有一个学术会议，我去参加了那个会议，我通过三次不同的互动在一天之内发现，我的三个不同的现任同事都在就业市场上寻找另一份工作。这三个人都是我的好朋友。所以我那天经历了一个我称之为附带冲击的相当大的冲击，我对自己说，我在工作中的三个好朋友正在寻找。离开。如果我留下来，那会是什么样的部门，我将不得不承担多少工作？为什么我没有考虑离开？所以我最终去那家机构面试并接受了一份工作。讽刺的是，我那三个寻找跳槽的同事最终留下来了，但我最终离开了。所以那是我肯定会回想起的生命中更令人震撼的日子之一。
And I would have been happy on that path too. And so I think that's important to realize is that there isn't always like one clear right and one clear wrong path when we experience these jolts. Often both will keep us on the path to the good life. We just need to make a decision and then move on with our careers. Anthony Klotz is the author of Jolted, Why We Quit, When to Stay, and Why It Matters. Anthony, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been my absolute pleasure.
回顾过去，你觉得你做出了正确的决定吗，安东尼？是的，绝对。而且，你知道，转到不同的机构让我能够在我的职业生涯中做我想做的事情，而我本来是不可能做到的。但这并不是说，你知道，如果我留下来，而是大声说出来并要求加薪，比如说。就像，看，除了我以外，每个人都在找工作。我应该加薪。谁知道呢？也许他们会，你知道，给我加薪和其他一些福利。
Making our way through life jolting moments can be difficult. It's destabilizing when the ground shifts under our feet. And sometimes a big jolt can lead to a series of smaller jolts, like the aftershocks of an earthquake. A listener named Eileen experienced this five years into a happy relationship. Her partner wanted her to move with him to a property that he owned in another state. Eileen was reluctant because she loved her home. It had been in her family for four generations, but she decided to make the move.
我也会在那条路上感到快乐。所以我认为意识到这一点很重要，那就是当我们经历这些突发事件时，并不总是有明确的一条正确路径和一条明确的错误路径。通常两者都会让我们保持在通往美好生活的道路上。我们只需要做出决定，然后继续我们的职业生涯。安东尼·克洛茨是《震撼：我们为什么辞职，何时留下，以及为什么这很重要》的作者。安东尼，非常感谢你今天加入 Hidden Brain。这是我的绝对荣幸。
Because the move made sense on paper, and through the overseeing guidance and support of my therapist of many years, I eventually agreed to the move with a handful of conditions he agreed to meet first. I made it clear that I wasn't going to micromanage these demands, trusting him to get them done. The night before our big move, with everything in my house packed up, moving truck loaded and in the driveway. We were happily eating dinner at a restaurant when, mid-chew, it was like a bolt of lightning, entered the top of my head and surged through my body
在生活中经历震撼时刻可能很困难。当脚下的地面发生位移时，这是不稳定的。有时一个大的突发事件会导致一系列较小的突发事件，就像地震的余震一样。一位名叫艾琳的听众在一段幸福的关系中经历了五年。她的伴侣想让她和他一起搬到他在另一个州拥有的房产。艾琳很勉强，因为她爱她的家。它已经在她的家族中传了四代，但她决定搬家。
with the voice I heard clearly say, he didn't do what he promised. I immediately said to him, you didn't do X, did you? We didn't speak another word that night, and in the morning the silence continued, but we each drove away in separate vehicles from my property to his. Eight hours later, literally the moment I crossed the threshold into my new life and home,
因为搬家在纸面上是有意义的，并且通过我多年来的治疗师的监督指导和支持，我最终同意了搬家，并附带了他首先同意满足的几个条件。我明确表示我不会微观管理这些要求，相信他会完成它们。在我们大搬家的前一天晚上，我房子里的东西都打包好了，搬家卡车装满了停在车道上。我们正在一家餐馆愉快地吃晚饭，这时，咀嚼到一半，就像一道闪电，进入了我的头顶并穿过我的身体
I began a future of unparalleled dysfunction and anxiety. Eileen says she stayed in the relationship for three and a half years. When she decided to end things, she was 62 years old, without a source of income or anywhere to live. When I finally pulled the plug on the relationship, the bottom had completely fallen out of my once peaceful and happy life. Now, two years later, I am still dusting myself off, struggling to completely reinvent myself and survive. She realized that the night before the move, she'd had an intuition that something was wrong. Why hadn't she paid more attention to that bolt of lightning?
我清楚地听到声音说，他没有做他承诺的事情。我立刻对他说，你没有做 X，对吧？那天晚上我们没再说一句话，早上沉默继续，但我们每个人都分别开车从我的房产到他的房产。八小时后，就在我跨入我的新生活和新家的那一刻，
My muse made an appearance and tried to get my attention. but it was inconvenient for me to break my commitment or to break the momentum of my plans, and I didn't take her warning. It is not an obvious happy ending, but I have learned from it. When we come back, more jolts of lightning. We examine the power of the unconscious mind
我开始了一个功能失调和焦虑无与伦比的未来。艾琳说她在这种关系中待了三年半。当她决定结束这段关系时，她已经 62 岁了，没有收入来源，也没有地方住。当我最终切断这段关系时，我曾经平静而幸福的生活已经完全崩溃了。现在，两年过去了，我还在清理自己，努力彻底重塑自我并生存下去。她意识到搬家的前一天晚上，她有一种直觉，觉得出了问题。为什么她没有更多地关注那道闪电？
to reveal the path forward. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Sometimes there's nothing more terrible. than a blank page, an empty canvas. The act of creating something new isn't easy. That's the case whether you're trying to write a novel
我的缪斯女神出现了，试图引起我的注意。但打破我的承诺或打破我计划的势头对我来说很不方便，我没有接受她的警告。这不是一个明显的幸福结局，但我从中吸取了教训。当我们回来时，更多的闪电。我们审视潜意识的力量
or figure out what to make for dinner. When we get stuck, we usually respond by pushing ourselves harder. But there are many times when pushing harder does not produce results. At those times, we may throw in the towel. We take a walk or lie down for a nap. And suddenly, out of the blue, an idea comes to us. We figure out the sentence to start the novel, or a key ingredient, around which to base the meal.
揭示前进的道路。你正在收听 Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是 Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。有时没有什么比空白页、空白画布更可怕的了。创造新事物的行为并不容易。无论你是试图写小说
Why do our brains work like this? And how can we become better at cultivating our inner muse? We talked about all this recently with psychologist Arp Dykstrahaus. He's the author of Inspiration, Where the Best Ideas Come From. Arp returns to the show today to respond to listeners, questions, and comments about these positive jolts. Arp Dexterhouse, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you. So, up, many of us assume that when we work hard on a problem that we're facing at work or in our personal lives, we're going to solve that problem.
还是想出晚餐做什么，情况都是如此。当我们卡住时，我们通常会通过更加努力地推动自己来做出反应。但有很多时候，更加努力地推动并不能产生结果。在那些时候，我们可能会放弃。我们去散步或躺下小睡。突然，出乎意料地，一个想法出现在我们脑海中。我们想出了开始小说的句子，或者一个关键成分，围绕它来制作这顿饭。
But of course, that's not always the case. Why is it that pressing harder does not always produce breakthroughs? Well, there's various reasons. perhaps the most important reason is that you tend to get stuck in one direction and you lose your flexibility and the one direction you get stuck in is not always the one that will help you to solve the problem. And if you put it aside for a while, then your unconscious will start to work on it in a completely different, much more creative way. And that often leads to a solution. You know, if you think about something too hard, it's like a very bright,
为什么我们的大脑会这样工作？我们怎样才能更好地培养我们的内在缪斯？我们最近和心理学家阿尔普·戴克斯特拉豪斯谈到了这一切。他是《灵感：最好的想法来自哪里》的作者。阿尔普今天回到节目中，回答听众关于这些积极突发事件的问题和评论。阿尔普·戴克斯特拉豪斯，欢迎回到 Hidden Brain。谢谢。所以，阿尔普，我们许多人假设当我们努力解决我们在工作中或个人生活中面临的问题时，我们将解决那个问题。
but narrow light shining on something. And what you often need is not so much a bright light, but a light that, you know, that meanders, that goes in all kinds of directions, that also puts light on things that you normally don't shed light on. So you have to let your unconscious do the job in these cases. We received many listener stories of inspiration in response to our earlier conversation up. Here's one from Chris in Arkansas.
但当然，情况并非总是如此。为什么更加努力地推动并不总是产生突破？嗯，有各种原因。也许最重要的原因是，你倾向于卡在一个方向上，你失去了灵活性，而你卡住的那个方向并不总是能帮助你解决问题的那个方向。如果你把它放在一边一段时间，那么你的潜意识就会开始以一种完全不同、更具创造性的方式来处理它。这通常会导致解决方案。你知道，如果你对某件事想得太辛苦，它就像一道非常明亮、
I'm a career automobile technician, and at times it's really challenging to make certain repairs, particularly on the electrical and electronic high-tech systems on automobiles. That's compounded by the fact that during the workday, there's a lot of pressure for production, getting things done in a timely manner. So it's not uncommon for me to sleep on a problem that I was encountering during the day and wake up in the same. in the middle of the night, having dreamed the solution to the problem. And I've learned from talking to colleagues, it's not just me. Some of my colleagues have experienced this phenomenon as well. Occasionally, I'll have to wake up and write something down, but more often than not, I'll remember it, I'll wake up in the morning,
但狭窄的光照在某物上。而你通常需要的不是那么明亮的光，而是一道，你知道，蜿蜒曲折的光，它向各种方向前进，它也照亮了你通常不照亮的东西。所以你必须让你的潜意识在这些情况下完成工作。我们收到了许多听众关于灵感的故事，以回应我们之前的对话，阿尔普。这是来自阿肯色州克里斯的一个故事。
I'll go back to work, and I will have my solution, or at least a strategy to arrive at a solution ready to go. So, as many listeners pointed out, there is a very important role that sleep plays in helping them arrive at moments of inspiration. What is the role of sleep in these eureka moments? This is truly a wonderful example of some of the phenomena I describe in my book. Well, the role of sleep is getting more and more important. The more research we do, and we aren't there yet. But what we know now is that especially during REM sleep, the sleep that produces the dreams,
我是一名职业汽车技术员，有时进行某些维修确实具有挑战性，特别是在汽车的电气和电子高科技系统上。再加上工作日期间，生产压力很大，需要在及时的方式下完成事情。所以我睡在白天遇到的问题上，并在半夜醒来，梦见了问题的解决方案，这并不罕见。我从与同事的交谈中了解到，这不仅仅是我。我的一些同事也经历过这种现象。偶尔，我必须醒来并写下一些东西，但更多时候，我会记住它，我会在早上醒来，
there's all kinds of cognitive processes playing in our brain that have to do with memory, with making new associations, yeah, fostering creativity. So, yeah, we know quite specifically that during REM sleep, which you engage in about five or six times in nights, sometimes for 10 or 15 minutes, sometimes a little longer. half an hour. These are the most important periods. You know, educators have told us for a very long time that students who pull all-nighters, you know, they stay up all night to study, they're not doing themselves any favors when there is an important test the next morning. Because, of course, sleep plays an important role
我会回到工作中，我会有我的解决方案，或者至少是一个准备好的解决策略。所以，正如许多听众指出的那样，睡眠在帮助他们获得灵感时刻方面发挥着非常重要的作用。睡眠在这些尤里卡时刻中扮演什么角色？这确实是我在书中描述的一些现象的一个绝佳例子。嗯，睡眠的作用变得越来越重要。我们做的研究越多，我们还没有达到那个程度。但我们现在知道的是，特别是在快速眼动睡眠期间，产生梦境的睡眠，
in consolidating learning. And based on what you're saying, you know, students might end up being less creative on the morning of the test if they spend the previous night staying up to cram. Yeah, memory consolidation is one of the first things that people discovered as it comes to what sleep is actually doing for us. So learning in the evening and then have a good night's sleep is way more productive than learning during the night. There's also experiments showing that if you have people learn something and then one group goes to sleep for six or eight hours and the other group has to stay awake, the first group is performing much better in all kinds of memory tests. And the second thing, of course, is that if you don't sleep, you're tired, it's as simple as that. And creativity also needs a well-rested mind.
我们大脑中有很多认知过程在发挥作用，这些过程与记忆、建立新的联想有关，是的，促进创造力。所以，是的，我们非常具体地知道，在快速眼动睡眠期间，你每晚经历大约五到六次，有时持续 10 或 15 分钟，有时更长一点。半小时。这些是最重要的时期。你知道，教育工作者很长一段时间以来一直告诉我们，熬夜的学生，你知道，他们整晚不睡觉学习，当第二天早上有重要的考试时，他们并没有帮到自己。因为，当然，睡眠发挥了重要作用
So you're actually not doing yourself a favor in two different ways. First, you're too tired. And second, you don't use these wonderful mechanisms that sleep provides you with. Listener, Ilana wrote in with a question about the types of problems that can be solved by unconscious thought processes involving inspiration. she writes, I couldn't understand what types of problems can be solved with the help of the subconscious and which cannot. What do you think up? Are the benefits of unconscious inspiration bounded to certain kinds of problems? That's really an excellent question. Yeah, they are in that if you think about something very focused and consciously, it's better for some problems or some decisions maybe that you have to make.
在巩固学习方面。根据你所说的，你知道，如果学生在前一天晚上熬夜死记硬背，他们第二天早上可能会变得不那么有创造力。是的，记忆巩固是人们在发现睡眠实际上为我们做什么时发现的第一件事。所以晚上学习然后睡个好觉比晚上学习效率高得多。还有实验表明，如果你让人学习一些东西，然后一组人去睡觉六到八小时，而另一组人必须保持清醒，第一组人在各种记忆测试中表现要好得多。第二件事，当然，如果你不睡觉，你很累，就这么简单。创造力也需要一个休息良好的头脑。
and the unconscious or the subconscious, as she calls it, is better for other things. Your unconscious is especially good when it comes to problems that are huge, when it involves large amounts of information. You know, where you have the feeling you don't even know where to start. And when a lot of the information that you have to use is more subjective, you know, also when it comes to making a decision when the information is more emotional. In terms of decision-making, you could make.
所以你实际上并没有以两种不同的方式帮到自己。首先，你太累了。第二，你没有使用睡眠为你提供的这些美妙机制。听众伊拉娜写信询问关于可以通过涉及灵感的潜意识思维过程解决的问题类型。她写道，我无法理解哪些类型的问题可以在潜意识的帮助下解决，哪些不能。你认为呢，阿尔普？潜意识灵感的好处是否局限于某些类型的问题？这是一个非常好的问题。是的，它们是，因为如果你非常专注和有意识地思考某件事，它对某些问题或你可能必须做出的某些决定更好。
a distinction. If you if you if you buy if you want to buy something where the different aspects are really technical like you know buying a new washing machine, it's perfectly reasonable to do this in a very conscious rational manner. You know you can take a piece of paper, a pen and pluses and minuses and pros and cons and and that's all fine. But but everybody would agree with me that once a decision becomes a way way more complex and also more subjective like buying a house where also some emotional aspects play a role, you have to also make room for your own unconscious. And if you focus on it only consciously in a very narrow way
而潜意识，正如她所称的那样，对其他事情更好。你的潜意识在处理巨大的问题时特别好，当它涉及大量信息时。你知道，当你感觉你甚至不知道从哪里开始时。当你有许多必须使用的信息更主观时，你知道，当涉及到在信息更情绪化时做出决定时也是如此。在决策方面，你可以做出
when buying a house, you're probably going to use the wrong criteria in the end. Many of us have had the experience of feeling inspiration bubbling up when we're young and learning new things. Listener Tracy had a question about whether that process slows down as we age. It seems that when I was younger, I had many moments of inspiration. In fact, I called my business, Muse Marketing, and Management because I felt inspired often. I made jewelry.
一个区分。如果你如果你如果你买如果你想买东西，其中不同的方面非常技术性，比如你知道买一台新洗衣机，以一种非常自觉、理性的方式这样做是完全合理的。你知道你可以拿一张纸、一支笔和加号和减号以及利弊，而且这都很好。但是但是每个人都会同意我的观点，一旦决定变得更加复杂，也更加主观，比如买房子，其中一些情感方面也发挥作用，你也必须为自己的潜意识留出空间。如果你只以一种非常狭窄的方式有意识地关注它
I did all kinds of creative things. And as I've gotten older, I've continued creative pursuits, but more in my part-time in my off-time than during my working hours. I'm wondering if as we get older, if inspiration comes less and less often, or if maybe we are in more of a fixed mindset and unwilling or unable to be curious, that's it. Thank you for taking my question. What do you think of Tracy's questioner? There's this old classic psychology study where people devise, a test battery to measure creativity. And it turned out that the question, what can you do with a paper
在买房子时，你最终可能会使用错误的标准。我们许多人都有过在年轻和学习新事物时感到灵感迸发的经历。听众特雷西有一个关于那个过程是否随着我们年龄增长而减慢的问题。似乎当我年轻的时候，我有很多灵感时刻。事实上，我把我的公司命名为缪斯营销与管理，因为我经常感到灵感。我制作珠宝。
clip, a very simple question, was very central in that test battery. And then the research is doing that experiment. They looked at the answers people gave and they made a distinction between people that were very, very good and they called them highly creative. And it turns out among young children, almost everybody scored very highly on creativity. They did way, way better than the adults. And that led to the development of a theory that there's really two kinds of thinking. One is divergent thinking, that is the wild, associative, creative thinking, and the other is convergence thinking. That's the sort of the voice in your head saying things like, oh, but is this really necessary? Oh, is this possible? Isn't this too expensive? You know, this is that you could say
我做了各种各样的创造性事情。随着年龄的增长，我继续进行创造性追求，但更多是在我的兼职时间、我的休息时间，而不是在我的工作时间。我想知道随着年龄的增长，灵感是否越来越少，或者也许我们处于一种更固定的心态中，不愿意或无法好奇，就是这样。感谢你回答我的问题。你认为特雷西的问题怎么样？有一个古老的经典心理学研究，人们设计了一个测试电池来衡量创造力。结果发现，问题，你能用回形针做什么，
Divergent thinking is the gas pedal in the car, and convergent thinking is the brake. Now, it turns out that divergent thinking is something you're basically born with. It's in you as a child. It's very active as a child. And convergent thinking is something you learn over life. And that makes you less creative when you grow older, or at least it feels like you're less creative or not as often inspired. it's because the convergent thinking kicks in more and more often and often, and usually also way too early in the process. And being creative and being inspired, one way to put it is trying to find that child, you know, in yourself.
一个非常简单的问题，在那个测试电池中非常核心。然后研究人员在做那个实验。他们查看了人们给出的答案，并区分了那些非常、非常好的人，他们称他们为高度创造性。结果发现，在幼儿中，几乎每个人在创造力方面都得分很高。他们比成年人做得好得多。这导致了一种理论的发展，即实际上有两种思维。一种是发散性思维，那是狂野的、联想的、创造性的思维，另一种是收敛性思维。那是你脑海中说出诸如，哦，但这真的有必要吗？哦，这可能吗？这太贵了吗？你知道，这是你可以说的
You know, go for that divergent thinking and forget about convergent thinking. In some ways, I think what I hear you saying is that, of course, both are important to use your analogy of the car. you know, a car with just a gas pedal is a dangerous car, a car with just a brake doesn't go anywhere. The question is how to find a balance between those two things. And what I hear you saying is that many older people have come to use the brake so often that they've forgotten to use the gas pedal. Exactly. They may use the gas pedal, but it's immediately inhibited. Yeah.
发散性思维是汽车的油门，收敛性思维是刹车。现在，事实证明，发散性思维是你基本上与生俱来的东西。它作为孩子在你体内。它作为孩子非常活跃。而收敛性思维是你一生中学习的东西。这让你在长大后创造力降低，或者至少感觉你创造力降低或没有那么频繁地受到启发。这是因为收敛性思维越来越频繁地介入，通常也太早介入过程。而变得有创造力和受到启发，一种表达方式是尝试找到那个孩子，你知道，在你内心。
And we have to learn to not use the brake too often and to tell ourselves, you know, maybe next week, but this week, you know, I want to do something else. and forget about the breaks. Yes, maybe it's a little dangerous, but that's part of creativity too sometimes. One way to see the world from a fresh perspective at any age is to have an encounter with art of some kind, a painting or a song or a dance performance. You like to say that art begets art.
你知道，去追求那种发散性思维，忘记收敛性思维。在某些方面，我想我听到你说的是，当然，两者都很重要，使用你的汽车类比。你知道，只有油门的汽车是一辆危险的汽车，只有刹车的汽车哪里也去不了。问题是如何在这两件事之间找到平衡。而我听到你说的是，许多老年人已经习惯了经常使用刹车，以至于他们忘记了使用油门。完全正确。他们可能会使用油门，但它立即被抑制了。是的。
What do you mean by this, op? Yes, the art begets art. The overarching sort of theory, philosophical theory, in psychology and neuroscience these days, is that your brain is basically a prediction machine. What we are doing with our brains is we continuously update a prediction of what is going to happen in the near future
我们必须学会不要太频繁地使用刹车，并告诉自己，你知道，也许下周，但这周，你知道，我想做点别的。并忘记刹车。是的，也许这有点危险，但这有时也是创造力的一部分。在任何年龄以新鲜视角看待世界的一种方式是接触某种艺术，一幅画、一首歌或一场舞蹈表演。你喜欢说艺术产生艺术。
and also in a somewhat more distant future. We're trying to predict things. You know, if you want to be creative, you have to almost like challenge that prediction machine. You have to show it things that it doesn't predict. It makes your brain more flexible. It leads to new associations. And how do you do that?
你所说的这是什么意思，阿尔普？是的，艺术产生艺术。当今心理学和神经科学中总体的某种理论，哲学理论，是你的大脑基本上是一个预测机器。我们用大脑所做的是，我们不断更新对不久的将来将要发生的事情的预测
well, there's various things to do it. One is indeed art. You know, art is challenging your prediction machine. It's confronting yourself with something that you don't expect. Another good way is, you know, to go and travel to very distinct cultures. Or to talk to very, very inspiring people, you know. But yes, art begets art. Art is something that challenges your prediction machine and that causes creativity.
以及在某种程度上更遥远的未来。我们试图预测事情。你知道，如果你想有创造力，你几乎必须像挑战那台预测机器一样。你必须向它展示它没有预测到的东西。它使你的大脑更灵活。它导致新的联想。你该怎么做？
When we come back, the relationship between positive thinking and inspiration. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. How often has someone told you to sleep on it when you have a problem you couldn't solve? Did it work? Today, we're hearing about stories of inspiration and talking with Arp Dexterhouse. He's a psychologist and author of the book, Inspiration, where the best ideas come from. Up here's a story of inspiration that we received from a listener named Bill in Pennsylvania.
嗯，有各种各样的事情可以做。一个是确实是艺术。你知道，艺术正在挑战你的预测机器。它让你面对你意想不到的事情。另一个好方法是，你知道，去旅行到非常独特的文化。或者与非常、非常有灵感的人交谈，你知道。但是的，艺术产生艺术。艺术是挑战你的预测机器的东西，这会导致创造力。
He says that as a sophomore in high school in 1979, he got told off by his band teacher, Mr. Price, for surreptitiously reading during band practice. He writes, Fast forward 40 years to 2019, I am presently a machine learning researcher for Lockheed Martin. Early in the year, my manager asked if I was interested in pursuing the Lockheed Martin Fellows' career, path. This is a rigorous series of technical and professional milestones, each lasting two to three years. At this time, my career was doing well, and I was very busy with both my work and home life. I knew that going down the fellow's track would be very difficult. I told my manager I would give it some thought, but in the back of my mind, I was really hedging against it. The day after
他说，1979年他上高二时，因为在乐队排练期间偷偷看书，被他的乐队老师普莱斯先生训斥了一顿。他写道：快进40年到2019年，我目前是洛克希德·马丁公司的一名机器学习研究员。年初，我的经理问我是否有兴趣追求洛克希德·马丁研究员的职业道路。这是一系列严格的技术和专业里程碑，每个阶段持续两到三年。当时，我的职业生涯发展顺利，工作和家庭生活都非常忙碌。我知道走研究员这条路会非常困难。我告诉经理我会考虑一下，但在内心深处，我其实是在回避它。在……的第二天
telling my manager I think about it, I went to sleep, and I had the most vivid dream, reliving that exact scenario from 40 years in the past. I had my book. I was in band class. I was going to sit behind the trumpets and Mr. Price came charging up the band risers asking me what the hell I was doing. But here's where everything in the dream changed and my unconscious took over. The background faded away. The music stopped playing and Mr. Price looked at me saying, Bill, you only get one shot at this. Never waste an opportunity. You will never know what would have happened unless you try it. it. And I woke up. I remembered the dream perfectly, writing it down because it was so shocking. Somehow, my unconscious mind, through Mr. Price, was telling me that I should really take the leap,
告诉经理我会考虑之后，我睡着了，做了一个最生动的梦，重温了40年前的那一幕。我拿着书。我在乐队课上。我正要坐在小号手后面，普莱斯先生冲上乐队看台，问我到底在干什么。但就在这里，梦里的一切都变了，我的潜意识接管了一切。背景消失了。音乐停止了，普莱斯先生看着我说：比尔，你只有一次机会。永远不要浪费机会。除非你尝试，否则你永远不会知道会发生什么。然后我醒了。我清楚地记得这个梦，并把它写了下来，因为它太令人震惊了。不知何故，我的潜意识通过普莱斯先生告诉我，我真的应该放手一搏，
do the hard work, and go through the Lockheed Martin Technical Fellows process. The next day, I emailed my manager and told him I was ready to start the process. Up, what do you make of Bill's story? Yeah, it's a wonderful example of how such a clear form of inspiration from your unconscious especially during sleep, is quite rare, but it's not unheard of. And this is a wonderful example. And it happened to me actually roughly a year ago where I had a dream that in that dream, I felt the urge to write a children's book about the upcoming fascism in, you know, various
努力工作，完成洛克希德·马丁技术研究员的流程。第二天，我给经理发了邮件，告诉他我准备好开始这个流程了。阿尔普，你对比尔的故事怎么看？是的，这是一个很好的例子，说明这种来自潜意识的清晰灵感，尤其是在睡眠期间，是相当罕见的，但并非闻所未闻。这是一个很好的例子。事实上，大约一年前我也遇到过这种情况，当时我做了一个梦，在梦中，我感到有一种冲动，想写一本关于即将到来的法西斯主义的儿童读物，你知道，在世界各地的……
countries around the world. When I woke up in the morning, I still remembered enough to actually make some notes. and now the book is actually at my publisher will appear in a couple months. Wow. They're wonderful examples of how important our unconscious mind is and how it can manifest itself
世界各国。当我早上醒来时，我仍然记得足够多的内容来做一些笔记。现在这本书已经在我的出版商那里了，几个月后就会出版。哇。这些很好的例子说明了我们的潜意识有多么重要，以及它如何能够表现出来
even during REM sleep. It seems that inspiration comes to us most often when we're in a rather relaxed or even meditative state. You've actually conducted a study with Zen meditators looking at how the practice of meditation affects the transfer of insight from the unconscious to the conscious mind.
即使是在快速眼动睡眠期间。似乎灵感最常在我们处于相当放松甚至冥想状态时降临。你实际上对禅修者进行了一项研究，观察冥想练习如何影响洞察力从潜意识向意识的转移。
Tell me about it. the study and what you found up? What we did in that study was actually, it's quite straightforward. We asked people questions that could be answered with two, three or four different answers, like name one of the Beatles or name one of the colors of the American flag. And before these questions, we subliminally presented on a computer screen, we presented one of the possible answers. And then you ask the question and you see whether they actually use that unconsciously activated answer.
跟我说说这项研究以及你的发现吧，阿尔普？我们在那项研究中所做的事情实际上非常简单。我们问人们一些可以用两、三个或四个不同答案回答的问题，比如列举披头士乐队的一名成员，或者列举美国国旗的一种颜色。在这些问题之前，我们在电脑屏幕上潜意识地呈现了其中一个可能的答案。然后你问这个问题，看看他们是否真的使用了那个被潜意识激活的答案。
And it turns out after 20 minutes of Zen meditation, people actually do use these answers much more often than on the basis of chance. And under normal conditions, so without meditation before and they don't use the answers. So it was one way in which we could show that active information in the unconscious is transferred to consciousness easier or better after a brief. period of Zen meditation. And why do you think this is up? If you look at classic meditation technique, most of them are really about concentration. What you are doing is trying to look deeper into your own mind.
结果发现，在20分钟的禅修之后，人们确实比随机情况下更频繁地使用这些答案。而在正常条件下，也就是之前没有冥想的情况下，他们不会使用这些答案。所以这是我们展示潜意识中的活跃信息在经过短暂的禅修后更容易或更好地转移到意识中的一种方式。你认为这是为什么，阿尔普？如果你看看经典的冥想技巧，它们大多确实是关于专注的。你所做的是试图更深入地观察你自己的思想。
So almost in a literal sense, what you are doing is you increase the traffic between consciousness and the deeper unconscious regions of your mind. And that's indeed what we showed. So besides formal meditation, up. You say that the meditative state of mind that facilitates insight can come about in the course of daily life. In this regard, scientists sometimes talk about the three bees. What are these three bees? The classic three bees are the bed, the bus, and the bath. And yeah, scientists jokingly said that these were the moments where the possibilities on having a really good idea, an insightful idea,
所以从字面上看，你所做的是增加了意识与你思想中更深层的潜意识区域之间的流量。这确实是我们所展示的。所以除了正式的冥想，阿尔普。你说促进洞察力的冥想心态可以在日常生活中产生。在这方面，科学家有时会谈论三个B。这三个B是什么？经典的三个B是床（bed）、公交车（bus）和浴缸（bath）。是的，科学家开玩笑说，这些时刻是产生好主意、洞察力想法的可能性……
inspiration and also the last hour, half hour before you really wake up and you're sort of in this half sleep is also for many people a very productive moment. And in the car or public transport or train or plane is also known to be a moment where people do get good ideas. I want to play you a message from a listener we received about the power of walking. This is listener, Polly. I was ordained as an interfaith minister in New York and had taken a class on pilgrimages in seminary and decided to set forth from Saint-Jean-Pierre to Port France over the border into Spain and walk the 500 miles of the Camino de Santiago French route on my way to Santiago, Spain,
灵感，以及你真正醒来前的最后一个小时、半小时，你处于那种半睡半醒的状态，对许多人来说也是一个非常高效的时刻。在汽车、公共交通工具、火车或飞机上，也被认为是人们获得好主意的时刻。我想播放一段我们收到的关于步行力量的听众留言。这是听众波莉。我在纽约被任命为跨宗教牧师，在神学院上过关于朝圣的课，并决定从圣让-皮耶德波尔出发，越过边境进入西班牙，步行500英里圣地亚哥朝圣之路的法国路线，前往西班牙圣地亚哥，
which took me almost 41 days. and I decided to hike this route in silence and by myself for those 40 days as kind of an homage to my own creative process, what I wanted to do next in my life, and just wanted that time. I didn't really know what to expect, but when I started walking and was about 20 days in with an average walking distance of 15 miles a day, I started to notice my subconscious and my conscious mind became very cohesive, and I started to have visualizations and really was in a place that I had never experienced before. Polly goes on to say that it was during a sunrise walk on this journey that she had an epiphany, and it led her to create a non-profit organization. So up, talk about why walking seems to wake up something in the unconscious mind. of so many people? Again, this is really a wonderful story.
这花了我将近41天。我决定在这40天里独自一人静默地徒步这条路线，作为对我自己创作过程的一种致敬，思考我生活中接下来想做什么，只是想要那段时间。我真的不知道会发生什么，但当我开始行走，大约走了20天，平均每天步行15英里时，我开始注意到我的潜意识和意识变得非常紧密，我开始产生视觉化想象，并真正处于一种我从未经历过的状态。波莉接着说，正是在这段旅程的一次日出步行中，她有了顿悟，这促使她创建了一个非营利组织。那么，阿尔普，谈谈为什么步行似乎能唤醒许多人潜意识里的东西？这确实又是一个精彩的故事。
And when I studied the working habits of all kinds of geniuses in the past of scientists, but also all kinds of artists, there are quite a number of commonalities between all these people. One of them is that they are passionate and they work hard. But these things you would expect. But one other commonalities is they're all walkers. They make their daily walks, sometimes two, three hours, sometimes shorter. they all made their daily walks.
当我研究过去各种天才的习惯时，不仅是科学家，还有各种艺术家，这些人之间有很多共同点。其中之一是他们充满激情且工作努力。但这些是你所预料到的。但另一个共同点是他们都是步行者。他们进行日常步行，有时两三个小时，有时更短。他们都进行日常步行。
This goes one step further than, you know, merely taking a one or two hour walk. But even if you just walk for one or two hours, what you experience, it's like the boundaries between consciousness and your unconscious are slowly fading and they become, as she said, more cohesive. As long as you, you know, you really concentrate on yourself, you know, if you do this more often over a very prolonged time, these boundaries fade even more and you increase the chance that indeed your unconscious comes up with even a life-changing idea of what to do. When we come back, fostering your own founts of inspiration.
这比仅仅进行一两个小时的步行更进一步。但即使你只走一两个小时，你所体验到的，就像意识和潜意识之间的界限在慢慢消失，正如她所说，它们变得更加紧密。只要你真正专注于自己，如果你在很长一段时间内更频繁地这样做，这些界限就会消失得更多，你确实更有可能获得关于该做什么的改变人生的想法。当我们回来时，培养你自己的灵感源泉。
We'll talk about the relationship between setting goals and experiencing aha moments. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're talking with psychologist Arp Dykstrahaus. He's the author of Inspiration, where the best ideas come from. Up, we received a message from a listener named Ruan, who is an expert on the HPV vaccine. The human papillomavirus causes cervical cancer and a host of other health problems. One day, a colleague asked her how she would design a study to answer the question of whether a single dose of the vaccine would be as effective as two or three doses. Here she is.
我们将讨论设定目标与体验顿悟时刻之间的关系。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们正在与心理学家阿尔普·戴克斯特拉豪斯交谈。他是《灵感：最好的想法来自哪里》一书的作者。阿尔普，我们收到了一位名叫鲁安的听众的留言，她是HPV疫苗方面的专家。人乳头瘤病毒会导致宫颈癌和许多其他健康问题。有一天，一位同事问她，她将如何设计一项研究来回答单剂疫苗是否与两剂或三剂疫苗一样有效的问题。她在这里。
I had been studying HPV at that time for eight years and had read every paper and understood it deeply because it was the subject of my doctoral dissertation at the University of Oxford. And when she asked me that question, I immediately came to mind the trial design that would lead to the WHO changing its guidelines and recommending single-dose HPV vaccination. We conducted the trial in a record 18 months, including during the pandemic, ran perfectly on time, presented the data. And since that day, millions of girls who have not otherwise been vaccinated have received the HPV vaccine. And with India and China adopting single dose vaccination, we are on track to vaccinate 90% of girls and prevent cervical cancer in 90% of those young women as they age to. Adulthood, and that is thrilling. And it was thanks to the creativity, the deep learning and the moment of inspiration
那时我已经研究HPV八年了，读过每一篇论文并深入理解它，因为这是我在牛津大学博士论文的主题。当她问我那个问题时，我脑海中立刻浮现出了试验设计，这将导致世界卫生组织改变其指南，建议单剂HPV疫苗接种。我们在创纪录的18个月内进行了试验，包括在疫情期间，完全按时完成，并提交了数据。从那天起，数百万未接种疫苗的女孩接种了HPV疫苗。随着印度和中国采用单剂疫苗接种，我们有望为90%的女孩接种疫苗，并预防她们成年后90%的宫颈癌，这令人兴奋。这要归功于创造力、深厚的学习和灵感的时刻，
that we were able to solve this question. Thanks so much for a fantastic podcast. So up I find Ruan's story so wonderful, but it makes me wonder the extent to which deep background knowledge is a prerequisite for inspiration? Yes, most of the time it is. if you want to solve a scientific problem, of course you need the background knowledge.
我们才能够解决这个问题。非常感谢这个精彩的播客。那么阿尔普，我觉得鲁安的故事太棒了，但这让我怀疑深厚的背景知识在多大程度上是灵感的先决条件？是的，大多数时候是这样。如果你想解决一个科学问题，当然你需要背景知识。
And what she was talking about is highly specific and perhaps only a few people could have solved it in the first place. This is true not for all things, but definitely for most things. A good idea for a new novel will probably only come to somebody who writes novels. You know, it's not some random process whereby people on the street will also get these huge ideas. And the second reason is that motivation is incredibly important.
她所谈论的是高度具体的，也许只有少数人能首先解决它。这并非对所有事情都适用，但绝对适用于大多数事情。关于新小说的绝妙想法可能只会出现在写小说的人身上。你知道，这不是某种随机过程，街上的人也会有这些伟大的想法。第二个原因是动力极其重要。
You have to really want it for it to happen. Let's talk a moment about the relationship between goals and inspiration. It might not be intuitive, but you say that to create the conditions that generate insight, we can begin by setting the right kind of goal, one that's big and highly motivating. What do you mean by that up? Inspiration favors the people who really want to solve something, make something or create something. And the stronger the goal is, the more brain capacity you're actually using for pursuing that goal. That's also the reason why some of the more extreme
你必须真正想要它，它才会发生。让我们谈谈目标与灵感之间的关系。这可能并不直观，但你说为了创造产生洞察力的条件，我们可以从设定正确的目标开始，一个宏大且极具激励性的目标。阿尔普，你是什么意思？灵感偏爱那些真正想解决问题、制造东西或创造东西的人。目标越强烈，你在追求该目标时实际使用的脑容量就越多。这也是为什么过去一些更极端的
geniuses in our past were highly monomaniac. You know, the Newton died when he was 84 years old, but he died a virgin. He never had, he never made room in his life for something like love. Now, I wouldn't recommend that, but that's what he did. And There are a lot of examples of people who achieved way more than, let's say, normal people, but at the same time we're very monomaniac, simply because their brains were hijacked by their incredibly big, strong goal. You also suggest that when our brains are hijacked in this way, we are more likely to have faith in our intuitions? Yeah, that turns out to be true. There's various ways to test it.
天才非常偏执的原因。你知道，牛顿去世时84岁，但他死时还是个处男。他从未在生活中为爱情之类的事情腾出空间。现在，我不会推荐那样做，但他就是那样做的。有很多例子表明，人们取得的成就远超普通人，但同时又非常偏执，仅仅因为他们的大脑被他们极其宏大、强烈的目标所劫持。你还建议，当我们的头脑以这种方式被劫持时，我们更有可能相信我们的直觉？是的，事实证明这是真的。有各种各样的方法来测试它。
Yeah, people who really know what they want have a stronger intuition and also more faith in their own intuition. It's not so strange if you think about it. You know, what can your intuition do for you if you don't know what you want to do? Like you're walking in a strange city, your intuition can't tell you to go left or right if you don't even know where to go. And this is maybe a simple example. But this is true in life in general. Intuition works better for people who, yeah, who are motivated, who set strong goals. I mean, at a very basic level, you're walking through the streets of an unfamiliar city,
是的，真正知道自己想要什么的人有更强的直觉，也更相信自己的直觉。如果你仔细想想，这并不奇怪。你知道，如果你不知道自己想做什么，你的直觉能为你做什么？就像你在一个陌生的城市行走，如果你甚至不知道要去哪里，你的直觉无法告诉你向左还是向右。这可能是一个简单的例子。但这在生活中普遍适用。直觉对那些有动力、设定了明确目标的人来说效果更好。我的意思是，在最基本的层面上，你走在陌生城市的街道上，
but you know you're hungry, you're looking for a place to eat. And now perhaps your nose is more sensitive to the smells and odors that are coming from various restaurants that prompt you to say, okay, maybe I should go left instead of right. Yeah, exactly. Or maybe your ears too. You know, you think I go left because you hear a little bit more noise from that. side and you think the chances that I stumble upon a street with a couple of restaurants is bigger. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. So while we're living in a very data-driven time, in a variety of professional and academic fields, quantitative analysis is often seen as more reliable and
但你知道你饿了，你在找地方吃饭。现在也许你的鼻子对来自各种餐馆的气味更敏感，这促使你说，好吧，也许我应该向左走而不是向右走。是的，完全正确。或者也许你的耳朵也是。你知道，你认为我向左走，因为你听到那边有一点更多的噪音，你认为你偶然发现一条有几家餐馆的街道的可能性更大。是的，完全正确。所以，虽然我们生活在一个非常数据驱动的时代，在各种专业和学术领域，定量分析通常被认为更可靠和
insightful. We received a message about this from listener, Nikki. My biggest frustration is that when I come up with the insights and share them with other people at work, the people, the people I speak with are quite skeptical about anything that doesn't come from methodical, analytical work where I have facts and figures and data and metrics. And so any insights that I have that I know are true aren't trusted or believed. And they say things like, oh, yeah, you say that's your intuition, but we need facts and figures. So I would be interested to hear what you think. of that. Thank you very much for everything you do. What do you think is the right balance between data and intuition? And do you think we're living
富有洞察力。我们收到了听众尼基关于此事的留言。我最大的挫折是，当我提出见解并与同事分享时，我交谈的人对任何不是来自有条理的分析工作的东西都非常怀疑，因为我没有事实、数字、数据和指标。因此，我所拥有的我知道是真实的任何见解都不被信任或相信。他们会说：哦，是的，你说那是你的直觉，但我们需要事实和数字。所以我很想听听你对此的看法。非常感谢你所做的一切。你认为数据和直觉之间的正确平衡是什么？你认为我们是否生活在
in a time that in some ways undervalues intuition? Yes, I think we're living in a time that undervalues intuition, although I would also say that maybe 20, 30, 40 years ago, it was actually worse. I think I give a lot of, you know, talks to companies and government organizations. and my feeling is that there's actually a little more room for intuition than in the past. But the right balance purely depends on the kind of problem and the kind of decisions you are talking about. Again, if you're buying a new washing machine, the technical aspects and the numbers and the figures are probably the only thing that should count. You know, who cares about what a washing machine look like?
一个在某些方面低估直觉的时代？是的，我认为我们生活在一个低估直觉的时代，尽管我也想说，也许20、30、40年前情况实际上更糟。我想我给公司和政府组织做了很多演讲。我的感觉是，实际上比过去有更多的直觉空间。但正确的平衡完全取决于你所谈论的问题类型和决策类型。同样，如果你在买一台新洗衣机，技术方面、数字和数据可能是唯一应该考虑的事情。你知道，谁在乎洗衣机长什么样？
But when you buy a house, it's more complex. There's more emotionally charged information that you have to take into account. account, if you make huge personal decisions between your current job, for instance, or a job offer from somewhere else, or when it comes to things that have to do with love, you know, romantic love, you're not going to make a pro and con list. And that's hard to verbalize and you can't quantify it in terms of, you know, numbers. But it is incredibly important. So the right balance purely depends on the kind of decision people are making, but often the wrong balance is where they don't take intuition seriously and only want to base their decisions on facts and figures.
但当你买房子时，它更复杂。你必须考虑更多情绪化的信息。如果你在当前工作和来自其他地方的工作机会之间做出重大的个人决定，或者当涉及到与爱有关的事情时，你知道，浪漫的爱情，你不会列出利弊清单。这很难用语言表达，你无法用数字来量化它。但它极其重要。所以正确的平衡完全取决于人们正在做出的决定类型，但通常错误的平衡是他们不认真对待直觉，只想根据事实和数字来做出决定。
Very often, that's not a very good idea. You know, I remember speaking many years ago with Danny Kahneman, the psychologist who won the Nobel Prize in economics. And he told me about a very interesting story in his younger days when he was helping. helping an organization make decisions, and the organization was primarily relying on intuition and often making mistakes. You know, relying on intuition to make judgments and those judgments would turn out to be wrong. So he came up with a much more methodical way of collecting information, collecting data,
通常，这不是一个好主意。你知道，我记得多年前与诺贝尔经济学奖得主、心理学家丹尼·卡尼曼交谈。他告诉我他年轻时的一个非常有趣的故事，当时他正在帮助一个组织做出决定，而该组织主要依赖直觉，经常犯错。你知道，依赖直觉来做出判断，而这些判断结果往往是错误的。所以他想出了一种更系统的方法来收集信息、收集数据，
understanding the data, but then he had a really important insight, which is that after you collect all of this data, the right thing to do is to actually shut the book on all of the data that you've collected and then make the decision intuitively. And the point that he was making was that intuition in itself is neither good nor bad. It can produce bad results. It can produce good results. But when intuition is informed by learning and by discipline and by data, at that point, you're turbocharging intuition.
理解数据，但他有一个非常重要的洞察，那就是在你收集了所有这些数据之后，正确的做法实际上是合上所有你收集的数据，然后凭直觉做出决定。他提出的观点是，直觉本身既不好也不坏。它可能产生坏结果。它可能产生好结果。但当直觉受到学习、纪律和数据的启发时，在那一刻，你就在为直觉增压。
And I'm wondering what you make of that up. And if that's a way, in some ways, are squaring the tension that perhaps has run through our conversation between data and intuition. I have to say, I completely agree intuition that is not at all informed. is pretty much useless. And intuition by people who have a lot of experience can be incredibly useful. If there's a house on fire, the question is, can I still go inside to rescue something or will the house collapse?
我想知道你对此怎么看，阿尔普。如果这在某种程度上是解决我们对话中贯穿的数据与直觉之间张力的一种方式。我必须说，我完全同意，不受任何启发的直觉几乎是无用的。而有丰富经验的人的直觉可以极其有用。如果房子着火了，问题是，我还能进去救东西吗，还是房子会倒塌？
My intuition is useless. But, you know, a firefighter's intuition who's doing this, who's been doing this job for 35 years, is probably incredibly reliable and it's the best device you can get. But, yeah, when it comes to making an important decision, I completely agree with Kanemann. In my own work, we provided people with information pertaining to a decision like choose between four different departments and we give them a lot and a lot and a lot of information.
我的直觉是无用的。但是，你知道，一个做了35年这份工作的消防员的直觉，可能是极其可靠的，它是你能得到的最好的设备。但是，是的，当涉及到做出重要决定时，我完全同意卡尼曼的观点。在我自己的工作中，我们为人们提供了与决定相关的信息，比如在四个不同的部门之间进行选择，我们给了他们大量大量的信息。
And then we tell them to sit on it for a while, sleep on it, almost sometimes literally sleep on it and then the following morning, follow your intuition. You don't have to explain to me why you think this is the best department, you know, follow your gut. And if these steps are met, so first all this information, then a period of unconscious thought, then a quick, intuitive judgment, that's indeed the best way to make a decision. Yeah. I'm wondering where you find your inspiration these days.
然后我们告诉他们先放一放，睡一觉，有时几乎是字面意义上的睡一觉，然后第二天早上，跟随你的直觉。你不需要向我解释为什么你认为这是最好的部门，你知道，跟随你的直觉。如果满足了这些步骤，即首先是所有这些信息，然后是一段潜意识思考期，然后是一个快速的直觉判断，那确实是做出决定的最好方式。是的。我想知道你最近在哪里寻找灵感。
Do you have regular go-to places where you end up feeling inspired? It's interesting in the book I described the various faces that you have to stimulate your brain and do things that are a little bit weird, challenge your predictions, machine and then you have to engage in a more quiet period where you let your unconscious mullah over things. What I tend to do is I travel sometimes especially I especially like to go to big cities and they're always very inspiring. But I spent most of my time now living in a rather small medieval beautiful village but it's it's relatively quiet. So I travel and I go to big cities for my inspiration and then I go back home to actually do the work and let the unconscious mull over
你有固定的去处吗，让你最终感到受到启发？有趣的是，在书中我描述了你必须刺激大脑并做一些有点奇怪的事情、挑战你的预测机器的各个阶段，然后你必须进入一个更安静的时期，让你的潜意识去琢磨事情。我倾向于旅行，有时我特别喜欢去大城市，它们总是非常鼓舞人心。但我现在大部分时间住在一个相当小的中世纪美丽村庄，但它相对安静。所以我旅行，我去大城市寻找灵感，然后我回到家真正地工作，让潜意识去琢磨
things. And that's, for me, that's a kind of a rhythm. Psychologist Arp Daxterhouse is the author of Inspiration, where the best ideas come from. Arp, thank you so much for joining me again today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. We also heard today from psychologist Anthony Clarts. He's the author of Jolted, Why We Quit, When to Stay, and Why It Matters. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor.
事情。对我来说，这是一种节奏。心理学家阿尔普·戴克斯特拉豪斯是《灵感：最好的想法来自哪里》一书的作者。阿尔普，非常感谢你今天再次来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。我们今天还听到了心理学家安东尼·克拉茨的发言。他是《震撼：为什么我们辞职，何时留下，以及为什么这很重要》一书的作者。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
If you know someone who's in the midst of a life jolt or who could use some help cultivating their own inspiration, please share today's episode with them. You might just give them the tools to make a big change or find their own eureka moment. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你认识的人正处于生活动荡之中，或者需要一些帮助来培养自己的灵感，请与他们分享今天的节目。你可能只是给了他们做出重大改变或找到自己顿悟时刻的工具。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。